Mo, Mo, Mo, Mo, Monka W!
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
so leute ich bin doch übelst müde ich bin auch heute recht früh oder kann das sein
so 30 bin ich nicht sonst immer erst neun da aber ich war irgendwie schon relativ früh wach
und chat das habe ich verpasst
und tanzverbot
ja leute wo ist eigentlich der der freud ja oder ja doch so hieß er doch der immer
sonst zuerst geschrieben habe. Erster.
Was ist da los?
Warum ist er nicht Erster heute im Stream?
Aber der AF-Programmer ist da. Ja, dann.
Dann ist er zumindest
die Hälfte der Leute, die immer
Instant-Dart sind, da.
Hast du gesehen, was ich im Discord gelinkt
habe? Äh.
Nee. Hab ich nicht.
Warte mal.
Sack.
Übrigens, Leute, die Katz hier, ne
Die ist jetzt jeden Tag bei mir am Start
Und macht den hier bei mir
Ich hab Hunger
Deswegen gesagt, das ist nicht meine Katz
Die kommt aber regelmäßig bei mir vorbei
Und mittlerweile hat sie schon das komplette Haus in Beschlag genommen
Die geht jetzt auch immer in die Küche, legt sich auf den Stuhl
Und lässt sich streicheln in 10 Minuten
Moment, Moment, AF-Programmer, warte mal, warte mal.
Ich muss gerade mal Discord aufmachen.
Welcher Channel?
Ich kann das hier nicht anklingen, ich bin hier nicht eingeloggt.
Der mit den Katzenbildern oder was?
Welcher Channel?
Moin, LuckyDuck.
News.
Okay.
Der RF-Programmer.
Ja.
Du meinst das mit der Windkraft oder was?
Oder was meinst du?
Ach, du meinst, dass das
das Vera-Crypt
Vera-Crypt
Ja, ja, ja, das kenne ich.
Das habe ich auch schon gelesen.
Das habe ich schon gelesen.
Da gucken wir uns heute sogar ein Video zu an.
Habe ich vorhin gesehen auf YouTube.
Das muss ich mal schauen.
Aber es gibt jetzt schon mal Entwarnungen.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz das Emote ausmachen.
Keck, wait.
Es gibt schon Entwarnungen.
Keine Panik.
Der Veracrypt.
Chefentwickler oder so.
Oder wahrscheinlich einziger Entwickler.
Also der Typ, der Veracrypt entwickelt halt.
Der hat im Veracrypt-Forum geschrieben, er war in Kontakt mit Microsoft und Microsoft hat seinen Account restored.
Allerdings hat es erst funktioniert, nachdem der Outrage auf Twitter groß genug war.
Und dann hat sich Scott Hanselman eingeschaltet, das ist ein Microsoft Vice President.
und der hat das wohl intern weitergeleitet
und jetzt wurde sein Account wieder freigeschaltet
und jetzt gibt es bald ein Update, dass die
die Signatur vom
Bootloader
also
das Zertifikat
mit dem der Bootloader oder der Key mit dem
der Bootloader signiert wurde
dass das erneuert wird, dass das nicht
irgendwann im Juni ausläuft, also das Problem
sollte sich erledigt haben
mit Veracrypt, wenn es eine neue
Version gibt und man die updated hat
Theoretisch zumindest
Ob das natürlich passiert
Müssen wir mal schauen, die Version ist noch nicht raus
Aber es steht der Sache jetzt nichts im Wege
Dem sein Account ist wieder da
Also für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben, Leute
Benutzt jemand, wobei es ist ja kaum noch einer da
Aber ich frage trotzdem mal, benutzt jemand von euch, die schon da sind
Benutzt ihr Veracrypt?
Wenn ihr Veracrypt verwendet
Dann, also Veracrypt
Wer das nicht kennt
Das ist eine Software, wo du dein Windows-PC
Mit komplett voll verschlüsseln kannst
Also du musst dann beim Booten, so wie unter Linux, du musst dann beim Booten, musst du ein Passwort eingeben.
Und nur dann kannst du Windows booten, weil die Festplatte voll verschlüsselt ist.
Ich mach mal kurz hier meine Kiste an.
Und das kann ich persönlich auch nur empfehlen, weil wenn man mal seine SSD oder seine Festplatte wegschmeißen will.
Ja und auch wenn die vielleicht beispielsweise bei euch nicht mehr richtig lesbar ist, heißt
es ja trotzdem, eure gesamten Daten liegen dann im Müll, die theoretisch ja mit ein
bisschen Aufwand vielleicht noch auslesbar sind.
Allein schon, dass man dieses Problem ausschließen kann, ist Vollverschlüsselung vom PC sinnvoll.
So und das ist am besten, man macht das mit VeraCrypt unter Windows, dann hat man keine
microsoft kann keys restore geschichte mit bit locker und sowas wäre kürbisse und das
problem funktioniert auch alles wunderbar was secure boot und so funktioniert mit vera
kub mittlerweile alles problem war microsoft hat den account vom entwickler gesperrt einfach so
komplett brennen wir bespielen jetzt den account und nicht nur den account vom vera kub entwickler
sondern auch den account von wire guards und noch ein paar dinge müssen wir gucken uns gleich mein
ein video zu an habe ich hier gesehen und deswegen konnte der vera crypt
entwickler halt keinen neuen vera crypt version veröffentlichen und das problem
ist dass der bootloader von vera crypt der quasi secure boot fähig sein muss
sonst kann halt also also als bad defaults ok ist das kann der pc nicht
mal starten mit secure boot an und secure boot ist halt für vieles unter
windows erforderlich wie zum beispiel battlefield 6 spielen will weil das ein kölner level anti
cheats der halt auch secure boot haben will das braucht man und der bootloader war signiert mit
dem key oder zertifikat ich bin mir gar nicht das technisch hundertprozentig korrekt ausdrückt der
im juni 2026 bewirkt wird und dann könnten wahrscheinlich wenn aus pc ist mit werner
nicht mehr booten aber jetzt scheint sich das erledigt zu haben mit der nächsten vera
club version sollte es alles gefix sein hoffe ich mal so erste mal us update
aber hier aber jetbrains sachen rider wird geupdatet gab es wohl irgendeinen bug wenn
sie von 26 1 auf 26 1.0 punkt 1 updaten was new native wayland support was vor
vor schnell enabled by default linux ja wer hätte das gedacht dass es mal wieder
problem weil and w
was ist hier fehlt in den fonds fehlt
wenn kein kölner update dabei war doch war kein update dabei oder
oder? oder? oder? oder? oder?
naja kein kernel update dabei
dann reboote ich nicht, kein bock auf reboot
warum soll ich rebooten, wenn es gar nicht notwendig ist? macht ja keinen sinn oder?
oh doch, ok ich hab, na moment kernel headers, ok ja doch
kernel updates, aber der lts kernel juckt mich nicht, den verwende ich gar nicht
Aber Linux, Linux Cache OS, das ist glaube ich der Kernel.
Aber komisch.
Ah, jetzt kommt das.
Jetzt kommt das, worauf Bootloader Sachen und so neu generiert.
Ja, dann müssen wir gleich rebooten.
Jetgear.
Jetgear, ich wollte ja eigentlich dieses Wochenende, dass wir ein Niri-Einrichtungsstream machen.
oder vielleicht sogar 2, 3, weil ich gesehen habe, dass das ein doch recht komplexes Thema ist,
weil es nicht nur darum geht, Miri einzurichten, sondern auch um die ganzen Shells und Sachen drumherum.
Und da gibt es mindestens 5 verschiedene Shells, die man ausprobieren muss.
Noctalia oder wie das heißt, Dank Material Shell, Exo Celestia und ach, was es nicht noch alles gibt.
Muss man alles ausprobieren, also vielleicht dauert das auch mehr als ein,
gehe ich mal davon aus, dass es mehr als ein Stream braucht.
Ich wollte das eigentlich gestern machen, aber ich hatte gestern wieder ein bisschen mentale Probleme, nennen wir es mal so.
Oder eigentlich vorgestern.
Gestern war es schon wieder halbwegs gut, aber hat noch ein bisschen gebraucht.
Und heute ist es nochmal besser.
Ich steigere mich da halt immer so übelst rein.
Mein größtes Problem momentan komplett auf Linux umzusteigen ist Cubase, eine Musikproduktion, die kenne ich, ja, Produktion Software mit Latenzen und Audio 3D.
Okay, Audio unter Linux, ey, hör mir auf, hör mir bloß auf, ey.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, wo irgendwie kein Mensch mehr durchblickt.
Was ist denn eigentlich aktuell gerade angesagt unter Linux für Audio?
Ganz früher war es ALSA.
so also ist es ja heute glaube ich immer noch ganz unter der haube dann war es eine weile lang
oben drüber wie hieß das das von dem system die erfinder puls audio puls audio war das danach und
jetzt ist es bei bayer aber also ist es irgendwie immer noch ich blickst keine ahnung dann gibt es
noch jack gab es eine weile das ist so irgendwie zum netzwerk zum audio über das netzwerk verteilen
kalle leute da blickt wirklich keine saube durch also vielleicht bin ich einfach nur zu übelster
kacken was das angeht aber das kann ich mir vorstellen dass das probleme gibt ja audio
treiber glaube ich war dass viele hersteller eben keinen bock haben ihre treiber zu open
sourcen von audio interfaces und sowas wobei trotzdem erstaunlich viel funktioniert
Also mein Audio Interface
Ich hab ein
Schon seit ewig
Mototrack 16
Ist eigentlich immer noch ein
Nices Audio Interface
Die haben auch keine
Linux Treiber
Dieses Teil hier
Hab ich
Also eigentlich muss man das hier
Das hier zeigen, weil hier sind auch die ganzen Anschlüsse dran
Also man hat hier
Man hat hier vorne
hat man hier
achso ne doch genau
äh
das ist hinten
ne
das ist was anderes
was ist das
kenn ich gar nicht
genau hier so hat man das vorne
man hat Input
für ne Gitarre die ich nicht brauche
man hat Line In
und Kopfhörerausgang
und
hinten hat man dann halt
USB, irgendein I.O.,
was ich nicht benutze.
Moment, das hat ernsthaft noch Firewire.
Optical in, Optical out.
Ach, hier kommt
dieses I.O.-Kabel dran.
Und bei dem Kabel kann man dann halt den Rest anschließen.
Dann hat man auch zig andere Anschlüsse.
Also das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Das habe ich auch schon über zehn Jahre.
Und da gibt es auch keine
Linux-Treiber für.
So, gucken wir mal, ob wir noch ein paar
Auer-Packages haben. Chaterino wird geupdatet.
Von 2,553 auf
2,554.
Hoho.
Warte mal.
Gucken wir mal, dass wir nicht Supply Chain
attackt werden. Man weiß ja nie.
Okay.
Mittlerweile bin ich ja da echt vorsichtig.
Chaterino.
Chaterino bin.
Was wurde hier geupdatet?
10.4.
Kappa Launcher.
Was zum Teufel ist Kappa Launcher?
Twitch Launcher using Rufio.
Warum?
10.4.
Das war vorgestern.
Kann man gucken.
Wo ist das Git-Repo verlinkt?
New Changes.
Ah ja ja.
Oh.
Der Rasmus Carlson hat das gemacht.
so diff package release 4 neue checksumme von github chatarino release
stable ach ach das ist moment das ist das nightly
bild kann das sein wenn er hinten dran steht ach das ist das neue nightly bild
Achso
Warum gibt es ein
Stable minus
Nightly
Widerspricht sich das nicht
Sogar schon von der
Idee her, dass es ein
Stable Nightly Bild gibt
Oder bin ich zu dumm
Das zu checken
Ist Nightly Bild bei Default
Nicht eigentlich Unstable
Aber das gibt es hier gar nicht, guck mal
Das gibt es hier auf GitHub gar nicht
Chatge, was ist das?
Download Chatterino
Genug's
Jetzt bin ich aber echt verwirrt
Guck mal
Wollen wir danach mal suchen
Assets, da steht's
Ach, bin ich einfach nur zu blind
Wo?
Hier?
Oder wo?
Wo denn?
Wo steht's?
Andrix, ich bin zu blöd.
Also Night Release von 2022 macht ja schon mal keinen Sinn.
Das hier kann's ja nicht sein.
Moment.
Hä?
Ach so.
ach das hatte da einmal eingestellt ach so okay hier ist es hier ist es aber es
gibt was ich witzig finde guck mal hier der hat der hat das nicht
er hat das nicht angepasst das ist hier nicht dabei des downloadet sich nun
chatarino arch linux target set das ist aber nicht bei den bei den assets dabei
aber gehen wir einfach mal von aus dass das schon passt chatarino
excellent moin schön dass du am start bist
ist. Battlefield 3. Tja, leider ist also erstens Battlefield 3 auf der Konsole mittlerweile
abgeschaltet, aber das wäre nicht so wild. Ich spiele ja auf dem PC, aber die Server auf dem
PC sind auch übelst verbuggt. Kannst gar nicht mehr ordentlich Rush spielen. Battlefield 6.
Irgendwie schockt es mich nicht so. Was sagt ihr zu neuen LLMs, die nicht für alle veröffentlicht
wollen weil die zu krasse haben ja schlecht beurteilen
so zack zack das haben wir alles geupdatet jetzt müsste ich eigentlich
einmal reboot, als er den kernel neu lädt und dann können wir anfangen.
Das stimmt, das stimmt, das liegt aber auch nur daran, weil die letzten Bälle viel
übelst verkackt waren, vor allem das vorletzte.
was ich halt fragwürdig finde ist
die haben ja ein recht erfolgreiches
Game sogar gelauncht mit Battlefield 6
so
das fragwürdig ist
warum sie irgendwie schon wieder
gefühlt die halbe
oder fast alle der Entwickler abgezogen haben
so es gibt jetzt irgendwie alle Schaltjahre
mal eine neue Map und ein bisschen Gram
Also, wenn man das ernst meint mit Support, dann müsste das meiner Meinung nach anders aussehen.
Ist auch schon eingebaut.
Ja gut, das ist ja irgendwo normal.
Es bleibt ja dann meistens nur so ein harter Kern.
Und das ist das, womit du dann halt auch monetarisieren musst und gucken musst, dass das alles hinhaut.
Sehr schön und gut, aber die releasen ja auch nichts.
Da kommt irgendwie alle Schaltjahre mal eine neue Map.
Ups, jetzt habe ich ihn verdrückt.
Deswegen bin ich immer noch, ich weiß, das ist nicht sonderlich beliebt im Jahre 2026,
deswegen bin ich immer noch der Meinung, dass das alte Modell von MMOs mit dem Monatsabo gar nicht so schlecht war.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass ein Monatsabo ist da selbstverständlich eine Hürde
und dass man ein Free Tier zum Einstieg bietet, dass die Leute es ausprobieren können, ist ja auch vollkommen sinnvoll, ja,
weil keiner schließt heutzutage mehr ein Monatsabo ab, ohne dass er das Spiel sich mal vorher angucken konnte,
aber ich fand, dass, dass, dass, genau, genau, ja, also, oder sagen wir mal so, das war ja früher normal,
heute ist ja World of Warcraft eines der letzten Spiele mit einem Monatsabo.
Ich finde das sinnvoll, weil das Monatsabo hat einen großen Vorteil
Du musst dir nicht, also ich meine, ich weiß, bei World of Warcraft machen sie es trotzdem
Du kannst dir einen Ingame-Store sparen
Was auf jeden Fall schon mal für Spielerzufriedenheit sorgt
Du kannst dir einen Store sparen
Du musst dir auch nicht irgendwelche komischen Pakete und Angebote und sonst was ausdenken
Du kannst ein Spiel bauen, wo es wirklich um das Gameplay und um die Spielwelt geht
ohne zu überlegen, okay, machen wir den Grind an der Stelle jetzt vielleicht länger, damit die Leute im Store was kaufen.
Das haben alle die gleichen Voraussetzungen und das Beste, was also an so einem Monatsabo bei MMOs ist,
dass es ein relativ gut, so predictable Einkommen für die Entwickler gibt.
Ja, also es ist nicht so, dass heute oder von heute auf morgen 80% die Abo kündigen.
Also da muss schon ganz viel passieren.
In der Regel ist das relativ konstant, was man da sieht, was die haben.
Natürlich sinkt das auch mit der Zeit ein bisschen, wenn es neues Addon gibt.
Also geht es vielleicht wieder ein bisschen hoch.
Aber das ist relativ konstantes Geld, mit dem man irgendwie auch planen und kalkulieren kann.
Und man nicht jetzt irgendwelchen neuen Sachen hinterher rennen muss.
Also ich finde das Abo-Modell für MMOs, ich spreche jetzt nur für MMOs, finde ich das immer noch am besten.
Liegt vielleicht auch daran, dass ich Oldschool-MMOs gewöhnt bin, wo das halt so gewesen ist.
Ihr wisst ja, ich spiele immer noch ab und zu Dark.
Dark Hedgehog Camelot, das ist ein uralt MMO von 2001.
Auf einem Freeshot.
Ich spiele ab und zu Herr der Ringe Online
Auch ein uraltes MMO von
Ich glaube 2007
Ich mag einfach alte MMOs
Und am besten wenn es alte MMOs sind
Die noch ein bisschen Support kriegen
Was denkst du über Elder Scrolls Online?
Das ist eines
Tatsächlich eines der großen MMOs
Die früher, also die schon relativ alt sind
die ich nie gespielt habe.
Ich habe die Beta gespielt, damals,
als es das so im Preview gab.
Also bevor das Spiel erschienen ist, habe ich die Beta
gespielt und bin
überhaupt nicht mit dem Handling
des Characters, nee, das kann man so nicht
sagen, mit dem
Flow des Spiels zurecht
gekommen. Also wie man Mobs
angreift und
so komische Animationswindup
und das
ganze Battle-
Kampfzeug hat sich so komisch
angefühlt in der Beta, dass ich irgendwie
gedacht habe, hä, das fühlt sich so hakelig an,
hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Danach hab ich's nicht mehr
gespielt. Der Frasier hat das relativ
lang gespielt. Der hatte irgendeine PvP-Gilde
und haben da täglich
PvP
Kram gemacht.
Da hab ich, das kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Hab ich nie gespielt.
Ich glaube, dass
Minecraft für viele Leute das ist,
was für mich manche Oldschool-MMOs sind.
Das, womit
sie aufgewachsen sind.
Und ich glaube,
die meisten Leute, die gehen
gerne im Laufe ihres Lebens immer
mal wieder zu den Games zurück,
mit denen sie aufgewachsen sind.
Das ist halt je nach Generation
ein bisschen anders. Ich bin mit
Sachen auf dem Super Nintendo aufgewachsen,
mit Half-Life auf dem PC
oder mit Sachen wie
Dark Age of Camelot beispielsweise bei MMOs.
und das spiele ich heute immer noch gerne.
Ab und zu, ja.
Ich muss das jetzt nicht jeden Tag durchcriden, aber...
Ich frage mich, ganz ehrlich,
ich frage mich ein bisschen, was die Generation
Service Game macht,
wenn sie mal 30, 40 sind
und es die Service Games nicht mehr gibt.
Was ist das?
Spiel für Generation 6, 7 Roblox, würde ich sagen, oder?
Chat, was meint ihr, was das Generation Alpha Game wird?
Was die mit 40 nochmal spielen.
Also ich würde sagen Roblox.
Das Ding ist nur, dass es das dann wahrscheinlich nicht mehr gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe eher den Eindruck, ich glaube Roblox ist dann beliebter als Minecraft.
Aber kann auch sein, ja.
Ich meine doch Gen Alpha.
Ja, ist Gen Alpha nicht Gen 6-7?
Sind das schon wieder andere?
Ist Gen 6-7 Generation Beta?
Keine Ahnung.
Ist Roblox auch in Deutschland so blieb?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe nicht einmal in meinem Leben Roblox gespielt.
Kein Schimmer.
Aber ich glaube, das ist auch in Deutschland beliebt, Roblox
Aber ehrlich gesagt, kein Schimmer
Ich kenne Roblox eigentlich auch nur vom Hörensagen und paar Videoempfehlungen
Ich selbst habe absolut keinen blassen Schimmer davon
Ich weiß nur, dass Roblox wohl ein Problem hat, was so Pedoleute angeht
so nach dem motto hihi ich bin ein 13 jahre altes girl willst du mit mir chatten hihi
und wirklichkeit ist es irgendein 50 jähriger alter sack so roblox hier roblox aber wahrscheinlich
ist das stelle ich mir das viel schlimmer vor als es eigentlich ist und das ist eher so ein ding was
auf Newsseiten und so gepostet, wie in Wirklichkeit
ist es gar nicht so. Keine Ahnung.
Noch nie vorgekommen. Okay.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Roblox.
Ich kenne das nur vom Lesen.
Ja gut.
Chat, dann gucken wir mal, was auf
Shithub so trendet.
Also, zack.
Zack, das hier haben wir mal alles zu.
Wir gucken jetzt kein C++ Flame Video.
Sonst mache ich heute nichts anderes mehr.
Why the original Task Manager?
Sag mal, wie oft will der eigentlich noch ein Video drüber machen,
dass er den originalen Task Manager programmiert hat?
Das ist das 150. Video.
Ist ja irgendwann auch mal gut, ey.
Trending Repos.
Ne, ne, ne.
Go gucken wir nachher erstmal.
Was allgemein trendet.
So.
Okay, Updated haben wir.
Rebooted haben wir auch.
Chatterino müssen wir wieder aufmachen.
Upp.
Okay, Leute.
Ups.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen blöd, so wie ich das mache.
Ich bräuchte...
Ich bräuchte noch einen zweiten...
Ich bräuchte noch einen zweiten Shortcut,
wie ich die Maus hier
releasen kann.
naja, guck mal mal
Max, welche
Namen hat eigentlich die Katze, die immer
vorbeikommt? Gar keinen, weiß ich
nicht, welchen die hat
Ich sag einfach nur
Katze, vielleicht fällt mir noch ein guter
Name ein, aber wie gesagt
das ist ja nicht meine
aber der gefällt's hier
mittlerweile liegt die auch einfach 10 Minuten bei mir
im Flur rum und chillt
wo sie am liebsten rumliegt
ist in der Küche auf dem Stuhl.
Lässt sich 10 Minuten streichen
und haut wieder ab.
Okay, also
was trennt er denn auf GitHub?
Diese Woche so. Lass mal gucken.
Deep Tutor.
AI.
ei ei ei ei ei glaube ich zumindest wahrscheinlich auch ei
preisen tool for converting files and office documents to markt und ok nicht
ei ei wobei es ist von microsoft leute ihr wisst was das heißt oder das ist
wahrscheinlich weib code es fakt das ding
Das haben wir uns letztes Mal schon angeguckt, das ist nicht AI.
AI.
Okay, naja dann.
Guck mal mal, was bei Go so trendet.
Microsoft 365 Co-Pilot-Katze.
Ja, so würde wahrscheinlich der Microsoft-CEO seine Katze nennen.
Und dann muss er gleich, und dann muss er an allen erzählen, dass es disrespectful ist oder was er erzählt hat, sich herablassen über KI auszulassen.
Was gibt es unter Algol? Das können wir tatsächlich mal gucken, wenn du willst.
Nix.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Okay, wenn wir schon gerade bei Sachen sind, was trendet denn diese Woche bei Kobol?
wieder das wieder das gleiche wie das letzte mal moment es trennt mit null
sterben die woche bei der männer wie funktioniert das die kammer mit null
sterben die woche trennten in weekly das geht nur mit cobol
okay was was trennt bei go container stellt
ich habe absolut keine ahnung was das sein soll
oxy stellt ach ja das heißt doch schon gesehen
K.I.
Ulama
Helm
Kubernetes Template Zeug
Bestel
Das haben wir uns das letzte Mal schon angeguckt
Das ist so für Homelab Leute
Monitoring Alerts
Grafen in einem
Hat mich jetzt nicht so angesprochen
Go trendet
Zu Recht, Go ist
Eine meiner Top 5
Programmiersprachen
Also es ist ja immer
Weil wir es immer davon haben
Erster Platz
Ruby und C Sharp
Schwer zu sagen
Ich kann mich nicht entscheiden
Also Ruby, C Sharp
JavaScript
Go
Und das letzte ist tatsächlich C++
Auch wenn ich finde, dass C++ die beschissenste
Programmiersprache ever ist
Die nicht beschissen sein soll
Aber ich programmier gerne Microcontroller
Und da kommt man in C++ nicht vorbei
Wann hast du das letzte Mal was mit Ruby gemacht?
Ey, das ist so lange her
Ewig nix mehr mit Ruby gemacht
Und auch wenig mit C Sharp in letzter Zeit gemacht
Ja, das stimmt
In letzter Zeit hab ich tatsächlich viel Go programmiert
Ruby, also ich bin mir relativ sicher
Ich weiß sogar noch das letzte, was ich gemacht habe mit Ruby.
Also das letzte etwas umfangreichere mit Ruby.
Das war ein Pre-Commit-Hook für unser GitLab auf der alten Arbeit.
Das war relativ umfangreich.
Das hat am Ende irgendwie was weiß ich, 2000 Zeilen oder sowas.
Da wurde alles mögliche gecheckt.
Branchnamen, Linting und so Zeug.
und es konnte dann den Push abbrechen,
wenn das verkackt war.
Das war relativ unvergleichbar.
Das war mit Ruby.
Zählst du Bash als Sprache und warum ist es nicht in den Top 5?
Ja gut, weil ich in den Top 5 nur Platz
für 5 Sprachen habe.
Bash ist aber auf jeden Fall direkt dahinter.
Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss,
Bash finde ich ist keine gute Programmiersprache.
Gut, C++ auch nicht,
wenn es darum geht.
Aber in Bash mache ich viel.
Also wenn es darum geht, wie oft ich was verwende, ist Bash tatsächlich auf Top 1, weil Bash wird bei mir täglich verwendet.
Vielleicht sollte ich Ruby rausschmeißen.
Ich, ey, okay, ich weiß, ich weiß, was ich mache.
Ich weiß, was ich mache.
aktuell habe ich ja gesagt ruby c sharp javascript go und c++ dann würde ich dann würde ich eher
sagen sie schab oder würde ich eher sagen sie schab javascript go weil c++ für microcontroller
komme ich nicht drum herum auch wenn ich c++ mega scheiße finde und ruby ist dann wie sagen
sie immer in den in den in diesen top top listen videos auf youtube honorable menschen
Bash ist aber auch eine Skriptsprache
Da mache ich keinen Unterschied dazwischen
Skriptsprachen sind Programmiersprachen
Also jede Skriptsprache ist auch eine Programmiersprache
Ist doch egal
Ob du das am Ende
Zu einem Binary kompilierst
Ob das interpretiert wird
Ob das per Bytecode
Das ist doch vollkommen wurscht
Das Abstrakte
Oben drüber
kann man alles zusammenfassen als programmier sprache lazy geht ja nix für
mich haben wir schon mal angeguckt das einzige was für mich in frage kommt ist
geht auf der kommando j genau ist geht auf der kommando zeile
das andere gibt es nicht command line geht keine visual studio code plugins
keine idee plugins nix geht komando zeile ist die wahrheit ja das einzige was ordentlich funktioniert
und okay bis bis auf bis auf zwei sachen ja für umfangreichere merges mit konflikten lasse ich mir
gefallen wenn leute match tools verwenden wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss man kommt auch mit dem
default wim merge tool relativ weit ja wo das dann so markiert ist in der datei wo das anfängt
als damit kann man es auch 90 95 prozent aller konflikte lösen und das nächste ist wenn jemand
hier repos linux ja wenn jemand zum beispiel sagt er hätte gerne history craft wobei es da auch was
war das geht log- kraft oder so oder ja genau ja also man kann sich das auch anzeigen lassen
auch guck mal geht und geht lockt hat ein paar probleme wenn man sich das geht lockt anzeigen
lassen will vom linux köln das ist ein bisserl bis das war keine gute idee
jetzt habe ich kaputt gemacht also leute den kraft vom lino skandal anzeigen ist
vielleicht keine allzu gute idee ja gehen wir hier ppb champ ok also da habe ich kein
loch gemacht oh man white people happy templates kraft okay sowas hier so kommen
sie das geht zwar auch ist hier leiber da ist ein gut verkehrt vielleicht mir
auch gefallen ja kennt ihr geht auf deutsch ja
mit mir ist ja
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Initen, Pullen, Diffen, Squashen.
Also sprich, man soll dann nicht mehr innen eingibben, sondern eröffnen.
Ja, klar.
Ich habe Ruby nie wirklich ausprobiert.
Gibt es da auch so viele neue Versionen wie bei C Sharp Python mit neuen Features?
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich habe die Ruby-Entwicklung der letzten Jahre jetzt nicht mehr so stark verfolgt.
Ich habe den Eindruck, es gibt regelmäßig neue Versionen.
aber jetzt ohne es mega krass umzukrempeln.
Ich habe nur mitbekommen, eine der letzten Versionen haben sie sich wohl sehr stark dem Thema
so Runtime-Performance gewidmet und Ruby war irgendwie 15 mal schneller als davor.
Aber was neue Features, ob es da quasi jährlich super viele neue Features gibt, weiß ich nicht.
Glaube ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht.
Man muss nämlich echt sagen, Ruby ist eine sehr, hat ein sehr, guck mal, das war komplettes, das ist vielleicht falsch, ein sehr stimmiges Gesamtpaket schon immer gehabt aus Features.
Aber ich habe, wie gesagt, lange nichts damit mit Ruby gemacht.
Deswegen sollte ich die vielleicht auch aus meiner Top 5...
Wobei Top 5 Programmiersprachen heißt ja nicht Top 5, die ich regelmäßig verwende.
Sondern Top 5, was mir am besten gefällt.
Ja, da ist Ruby auf jeden Fall ganz vorne mit dabei.
Hast du schon mal versucht, Visual Basic 6? Weiter muss ich gar nicht lesen.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Habe ich nicht.
mit Encoding, wenn unter Git zu verwalten,
das ist Pain. Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Die ganzen alten Encodings sind Pain.
Ich habe mal einen Kurs besucht,
wo ich noch sehr jung war,
auf der Volkshochschule.
Und da haben wir Visual Basic 6 gelernt.
Da war ich, keine Ahnung,
1998 oder so.
Da war ich 14.
Da haben wir Visual Basic.
Und irgendwann haben wir da einfach nur
nach dem Kurs noch Half-Life gespielt.
Da haben wir noch an den PCs gesetzt
und haben da Half-Life gespielt.
Anstatt Zwischel Basic 6
zu programmieren.
Ja.
Und das ist das alte
Windows Encoding.
Windows 1.2.5.2
Ist das dieses Encoding
Wie
Oh ich hab vergessen wie das heißt
Das für deutsche
Dateien benutzt wurde
Westeuropäisch
Genau
Das sind das
Wenn du Webseiten hattest früher
die dann oben immer so komische
Ös und sowas hatten.
Encoding-Fehler.
Ja, ganz, ganz abartig,
Alter. Hör mal bloß auf.
Ganz, äh...
Ganz abartig.
Genau, mit Fragezeichen
und so komischen Sonderzeichen
und sowas oben.
Okay, Container Registry trendet, LazyGit trendet,
ETCD trendet.
Fast Enterprise, okay, AI.
Proxy,
Harness hatten wir schon mal, Silium ist
Kubernetes-Netzwerkstells.
New RP.
AI.
To-Do-App.
Realit...
Scanner.
TLS Scanner for Reality. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was das sein soll.
Was ist Reality in dem Fall?
Äh.
Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer,
was das sein soll.
Oder meint er für Reality
für die echte Welt, so nach dem Motto.
Ein TLS Scanner, den man überall
gescheit verwenden kann oder keiner.
WhatsApp-CLI-Netbird.
Kubernetes.
Okay, da sind
auch schon mal ein paar gute Sachen dabei gewesen bei
Go, die nicht AI waren.
Okay, jetzt für die Krustentiere,
Leute. Was
trendet denn blazingly fast
diese Woche? Goose.
AI.
FFF.
The fastest and most accurate
File Search Tool AI.
Was?
File Search Kit for AI
Agents, NeoWim, Rust
und...
Verstehe ich nicht, wie jetzt
das eine mit dem anderen zu tun.
MCP, NeoWim Users.
Okay.
Was macht man da jetzt?
FFFF.
Das ist sowas wie
FZF oder was?
sowas wie FZF oder wie?
Oder was?
Freaking Fast.
Ah ja, natürlich.
Fuzzy File Finder.
Okay, das ist sowas wie FZF.
FZF ist übrigens mega nice.
Muss ich jetzt gerade mal zeigen.
Für Leute, die FZF nicht kennen,
kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen,
eines der wenigen CLI-Tools,
die ich zusätzlich zu den Standard-Tools öfters
verwende, auch wenn sie nicht auf Servern
drauf sind, aber für so kleine
Helper-Skripts, die man nur bei sich lokal ausführt,
wo man was auswählen muss, ist das super, ja.
Also gehen wir jetzt mal hier zum
Beispiel, keine Ahnung, nach pwchamp rein, so,
hier haben wir folgende Dateien. Wenn ich jetzt ein Skript
habe, oder irgend so ein Helper-Tool oder
so, wo ich Dateien auswählen möchte,
wo ich sagen
können will, ey, äh, select,
select a file, dann
pipe ich das einfach nach FZF
und dann kann ich hier aussuchen, welche Datei
ich haben will.
Oder besser gesagt, jeglichen Input,
was ich auswählen will.
Man kann hier auch
Fuzzy
searchen
und so drin.
Das war jetzt mit den Files vielleicht nicht das Beste.
Also man kann da auch Skript-mäßig
reinpipen, was man will und kann dann hier
auswählen. Also FZF
ist super praktisch für irgendwelche
Skripts. Ich habe zum Beispiel
ein skript bei mir was alle haus namen die bei uns im ende bild stehen in ende
inventories stehen das sind wie keine ahnung 4000 haus
namen oder sowas und wenn man hier pw gen so pw gen geparkt man fzf also geht
ja pw gen
aber hier ein beispiel so jetzt haben wir ganz viele sachen
wir generieren mal 1000 ok 1000 bär und jetzt kannst du hier stelle euch vor dass wir ein
haus nahm jetzt kannst du quasi hier was sie fasi suchen drin den haus namen auswählen und
dann wird es nach ssh geparkt ich kann mich darauf verbinden das benutze ich so als selektor für
unser server inventory also das fcf finde ich super praktisch ist auch ein standalone binary
written in ich glaube go ich glaube fcf fcf ist in go programmiert
schau dir das mal an moment moment moment kann es nicht random irgendwelche sachen anklicken
hier im stream
was was will was was das kann ich jetzt nicht was was was bin ich da lesend
was bin ich da hessen
So, gucken wir doch mal.
GitHub FZF. Ich bin mir relativ sicher,
FZF war ursprünglich in Ruby programmiert
und wurde dann rewritten in Go.
Ja, guck, Go.
Das ursprüngliche, das
allererste FZF war, glaube ich, noch
in Ruby geritet,
geritet.
Vielleicht sehen wir das sogar noch.
Vielleicht haben die noch einen ganz alten Tag.
Guck mal hier, gehen wir mal zurück auf 0.10.
FZF.
Guck mal.
Rubi war das noch.
Ich muss immer noch mal sagen, ich zittere nicht.
Das ist diese Mausübertragungssoftware.
Ruby.
545 Lines of Ruby.
Und ab wann ist es nicht mehr Ruby?
Ist hier immer noch Ruby?
Ah, hier ist es nicht mehr Ruby.
Okay, der hat relativ schnell rewritten.
Hier ist es noch Ruby.
Und jetzt...
Boah, Leute, das ist aber ganz schön schnell immer größer geworden, ne?
Übrigens auch eine schöne Sache an Ruby.
Das eingebaute Regex.
Für die ganzen Pearl-Fans.
Ich gebe zu, das hier ist jetzt nicht das schönste Beispiel für schönen Ruby-Code, ja?
Gebe ich zu.
Aber Ruby ist eine sehr schöne Programmiersprache.
Das hier jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen weniger.
Was auch wieder...
Nö, man kann in allen Programmiersprachen die Sachen eklig...
...eklig...
...programmieren.
Basic Ruby on Rails App.
Haben wir hier irgendein schönes Beispiel für, dass Ruby eine schöne Programmiersprache ist?
Haben wir nicht.
Ruby, machen wir mal Rails weg.
Ruby.
Ja, sowas hier.
Guck.
Klasse ist Flyout.
Aber ich finde, Ruby ist eine super schöne Programmiersprache.
Ruby.
Gut.
Was ist deine Meinung zu Projekt
Glasswing Cloud? Ich weiß gar nicht,
was es ist. Klärt mich auf.
Ich habe letztens einen Videotitel
gesehen von
Fireship, wo Cloud Mythos
steht. Ist das das mit dem
geleakten Code von Cloud Code,
die das umgebaut haben, sodass es
auf GitHub bleiben kann?
Oder was ist das?
Ist was anderes?
Dann weiß ich nicht, was es ist.
Was ist Project Classwing?
Securing critical software for the AI error.
Ich gebe ein Video von Morpheus dafür.
was das steckt hinter klopp was mythos kohls die kate hat mit project class
mit einer initiative gestand auf basis von cloud mit uns gemeinsam mit zahlreichen großen
schwachstellen frühzeitig auszumessen okay das ist quasi ein tool was sicherheitslücken
sucht das heißt im endeffekt der kais lob bei curl wird noch größer
fixed
Wir können das FireShip Video schauen.
Stimmt, hast du recht.
Wir gucken uns das FireShip Video dazu an.
Cloud Mythos
is too dangerous
for public consumption.
Okay, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Da gucken wir uns das gerade mal an.
Aber vorher muss ich erstmal die Musik ausmachen.
Hast du das Video gesehen?
von dem Typen, der das Warenlager in Brand gesteckt hat,
weil sie ihn nicht bezahlt haben.
Nee, das klingt aber illegal.
Sekunde.
So leise, ne?
Sekunde, ich muss mal checken, wie man hier lauter macht.
Ist schon voller.
So ist besser.
Okay, jetzt ist es besser.
Die claimen viel.
Hat Anthropic nicht auch letztens gesagt,
sie haben mit Cloud Code einen neuen C-Compiler erschaffen,
der nicht auf GCC basiert und das Ding kann so gut wie nichts kompilieren.
Weil die Sicherheitsimplikationen eines Modells, der so möglich ist, furchtbar sind.
Während andere sagen, Anthropic ist nur das gleiche Modell-Release-Playbook, das wir schon viele Male gesehen haben.
Das ist so...
Das bin ich...
Das bin ich sehr...
und ihr schaut den Code Report.
Ich bin müde, Boss, weil jedes Mal, wenn ein neuer Modell kommt,
scheint es eine neue Form von Mass-Psychose zu bringen.
Midjourney war going to make all human art obsolete,
but now nobody talks about it.
GPT-40 had an entire subreddit feeling love for the first time.
And now Mythos, without even being publicly available,
has many feeling existential dread for the first time.
And the reason for that feeling is that during Anthropics internal testing,
they discovered that Mythos is basically a zero-day vending machine.
Es hat eine 16-jährige Verletzung in FFmpeg gefunden, die einen Attacker ermöglicht, ein militärisches Videofilm zu kreieren, das den Decoder in ein paar Bytes von Daten außerhalb seines ermöglichten Erinnerungsvermögens zu schreiben, die den Programm potenziell verletzen und nahebeinige Daten korruptieren.
Es hat auch eine 27-jährige Verletzung in OpenBSD gefunden, die einen remote Attacker ermöglicht, einen nullen Pointer zu triggeren, der sofort in eine OpenBSD-Maschine, die über TCP-Maschine anbindbar ist, verletzt.
Das ist wohl schlecht.
Warum hat mein Browser Kernel-Access überhaupt?
Das sollte ein User-Prozess sein.
in der Linux-Kernel, die es in eine Nachricht in einer Nachricht-Memory-Page überwiesen hat,
die das Passwort-Executable in eine schreibbare File umgesetzt hat,
die es dann überwrote, um den System vollständig zu beherrschen.
Ich habe in den letzten paar Wochen mehr Veränderungen gefunden,
als ich in meinem ganzen Leben zusammengefasst habe.
Und gestern, hat US-Tresur-Sekretär Scott Besant und Federal Reserve-Chair Jerome Moneyprincer Powell
eine urgenten Beratung mit Bank-CEOs aufgerufen, um zu warnen über die Sicherheitsdangers,
die von Mythos verursacht wurden.
So it's no wonder that Dario is pulling inspiration from House Harkonnen and locking down control of the Spice,
with the announcement of Project Glasswing, a new initiative that brings together a collection of companies that happen to pay Anthropic a lot of money.
In einem Versuch, die weltweit die kritischste Software zu sichern, durch Zugang zu Mythos.
Die Idee ist, dass Mythos zu gefährlich ist für einen Default-Config-NPC wie dich,
aber perfekt sicher in den Händen von einigen Trillionen Dollar-Firmen und Banken.
Anthropics Plan ist, dass die Fellowship schnell alle Weltsoftware aufbaut,
bevor jemand anderes ein Modell dieses kapabler baut.
Was, wenn es um Sinister Sam geht, jetzt, dass OpenAI nicht mehr als Fluffer von Slopgen-AI-Videos funktioniert,
hoffentlich jeden Tag sein wird.
Aber nicht jeder ist überzeugt, dass Mythos so kapabel ist.
Und sie haben ihr Subscription-Model irgendwie umgestellt, ne?
Ach so.
Ja.
Hä? Wo ist denn der Sinn davon?
Okay, jetzt wissen wir, ehrlich gesagt bin ich jetzt genauso schlau wie vorher.
Ich habe jetzt verstanden, es ist ein Model von Entropic, was wohl besonders gut darin ist, Sicherheitslücken zu finden.
Und wohl auch Agent-mäßig laufen kann und halt ganz viel Zeug ausprobieren und durchprobieren kann.
Und dass es Sicherheitslücken findet, wird dann halt dementsprechend teuer, weil es halt eine Weile laufen muss.
Okay.
Ah ja gut.
Das ist jetzt...
Genau, und es kriegt nicht jeder Zugriff
bisher auf das Model.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so
der Weltuntergang ist.
So.
Gucken wir mal.
Wollen wir das mal ausprobieren? Gibt es das hier? FFFF? FFFF ist...
kann man runterladen hier ich dachte man kann es auf der command line auch ausführen
Alter, was zum...
Alter, wie viele Downloads?
Da probieren wir nicht aus.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
AI.
Call your tills, rewrite in Rust.
Ich muss mich da immer wieder outen, was das angeht.
Ich verstehe den Sinn davon
Ich
Ganz ehrlich, ich check das nicht
Warum
Die rewriten
Haben die eine Übersicht
Was die rewriten alles
So LS und so Zeug
Und Feind
Und AWK
Und was es nicht alles gibt
Wo sehe ich denn jetzt welche
Welche Sachen da drin sind
Hier
Base 64
Warum muss Base 64
Warum muss das... Also hier, ne?
1, 2, 3, nach Base 64.
Warum muss das Base
64 Command, warum
muss das rewritten
werden in Rust? Ich verstehe
das nicht.
Sudo wird nicht rewritten in Rust, ne?
Sudo ist auch nicht Core Utils.
Warum muss
Base Name
rewritten werden in Rust?
Mittlerweile hat ja Ubuntu diese Core-Utils wohl standardmäßig bei sich drin.
Die haben da öfters ja auch irgendwelche Inkompatibilitäten.
Aber ich verstehe es wirklich nicht.
MV.
CP.
Hat irgendjemand, Chat, hat irgendjemand von euch schon mal gesagt oder gedacht,
wenn er getippt hat, okay, CP, run.csh, run.csa.back,
wenn er das getippt hat, hat er sich gedacht so,
Oh, wer CP jetzt in Rust programmiert
Wärs nicht geil
Warum?
Es ist ja nicht so, dass die original
Core-Utils irgendwie
Lahm wären oder sowas
Ist da Grep eigentlich auch dabei?
Ne, Grep, natürlich
AWK, ist AWK dabei?
Fein
Ich dachte, das sind alles Core-Utils
Hier, who am I?
Who am I?
Das muss unbedingt rewritten werden in Rust, Leute
Das ist wichtig
essentiell, Alter.
Wenn ich Who Am I nicht written in Rust
hab, fuck, Alter.
Macht aus meiner Sicht keinen Sinn.
Und aus Security-Sicht macht es meiner Meinung nach
auch wenig Sinn. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
die Core-Utils an sich, das ist uralt, das ist
tested as fuck und es läuft
ja alles User-Mode
mäßig, also
viel passieren kann da ja nicht.
Ja, das stimmt nicht ganz.
Theoretisch schon, aber wie oft gibt's da
Bugs? Ich weiß
nicht, also, den
verstehe ich immer noch nicht.
Wir können mal kurz gucken,
wie groß ist dann, jetzt gucken wir uns mal
kurz an, Source,
ähm,
ja, Bin, äh,
wo finde
ich denn jetzt hier beispielsweise
den source von who am i
ich checkte ich check die organisation von dem von dem repo nicht wir klonen uns das mal
ja aber das ist ja nicht das was in core utils drin ist
Ich weiß, dass es Rust-Alternativen für so gut wie alles Mögliche gibt.
Aber...
By the way, ich verwende übrigens immer noch Feind...
Wobei, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Nein, ich verwende auch ab und zu FD.
Aber in der Regel, ich verwende Feind,
Seed, AWK.
Ich verwende das aus...
Oder ich verwende auch noch das klassische LS
anstatt Exa oder sowas.
Das liegt daran, ich bin so oft per SSH
auf Servern unterwegs. Ich verlerne sonst, wie man
die klassischen Dinger verwendet.
Was nach Source?
UU muss ich.
Okay. Who am I?
Keiner außer mir eingeloggt. Sehr gut.
Who am I? So, wie groß ist das Ganze hier?
Source.
Who am I?
Äh, nicht Main.rs.
Ah.
Was ist denn unter Plattform?
Unix?
Ah.
Okay. Who am I?
S.
Hui
Gut, dass das rewritten in Rust ist
Es ist ja nicht verkehrt
Ich sag ja nicht dagegen
Ich hab ja nichts dagegen, dass einer da seine Zeit reinsteckt
Es ist bestimmt ein super Projekt
Um was zu lernen
Aber ich versteh den Sinn
Dahinter wirklich nicht
Warum muss man
Who am I rewritten in Rust
Okay, wir fragen mal
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Was ist der Sinn dahinter Core Utils in Rust zu rewriten?
Das fragen wir jetzt mal mehrere KIs, weil JetGPT sich wieder garantiert irgendwas zusammen
fantasiert
Und die China Chinesen fragen wir auch
Okay, also was sagt ChatGPD dazu?
Kurz gesagt, der Sinn ist nicht, weil Rust cooler ist.
Ich behaupte, ein ganz großer Teil davon ist, weil Rust die Leute cooler empfinden.
Sondern mehrere ganz konkrete technische und praktische Ziele.
Das kann sein, aber ich könnte wetten, ohne Scheiß, Leute, ich könnte wetten,
Der Ursprungsgedanke dahinter ist, Placingly Fast written in Rust, das ist cooler in Rust als in C.
Ich erkläre dir mal ehrlich und ohne Hype.
Alter, dieses Gelaber von ChatGPT immer.
Ah, Classic. Classic Rust Gotcha.
Die haben ja bei Ubuntu auch laufend Probleme, weil das nicht hundertprozentig kompatibel ist.
Was ist überhaupt Core Utils?
Ist eine neue Impulse der klassischen Gnu-Tools.
Ja.
Möglichst Drop-in-Replacement.
Echte Gründe für den Rewrite.
Memory Safety, der wichtigste Punkt.
Anfällig für Buffer, Overflows, User-After-Free-Undefined-Fan...
Ja, okay, okay, das stimmt.
Das stimmt schon.
Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen.
Die, diese, die, die, die, die, die Original-Core-Utils, ja.
Die sind tested as fuck.
muss man da schon mal sagen
und das ist ja nix
irgendwie, das ist ja rein
User mäßig wo das ausgeführt
wird
ja da kann es natürlich
Bugs geben, also es könnte
was weiß ich, es könnte theoretisch
in CAT
könnte es einen Bug geben oder bei
LS könnte es theoretisch
einen Bug geben, wenn eine
Datei, wenn ein Dateiname
auf eine bestimmte
Art und Weise manipuliert wurde
mit was weiß ich wie vielen komischen
Sonderzeichen drin, dass das
dann eventuell in
LS irgendeinen
Bug auslöst,
der dann wiederum dazu führt,
dass weiterer Code, der noch
im Dateinamen-Code
ist irgendwie ausgeführt. Ja, das kann man sich
alles irgendwie zusammen, aber
wie oft passiert denn das wirklich?
Also,
theoretisch gibt es die Möglichkeiten immer.
Übrigens, Rust schützt da auch nicht vor allem.
Also vor Logikfehlern oder Mistprogrammiert
schützt Rust auch nicht.
Ich bin bei einem Könnte.
Ja gut, die Rust-Dinger
können auch Fehler haben.
Die können vielleicht jetzt nicht klassisch irgendwie
ich greife auf einen Array-Index zu,
den es größer ist als das Array selber
oder ich free irgendwas und greife da.
Das vielleicht nicht,
aber die könnten genauso gut Fehler haben.
Irgendjemand hat Mist programmiert
und es verhält sich Mist.
Ja, also sowas wie,
ey, guck mal,
RM löscht die falschen Dateien.
Das kann dir in einem Rust-RM genauso passieren
wie in einem alten Core-Utils-RM.
Und die Chance,
dass sie das in einem rast rm passiert ist sogar höher weil es bei weitem nicht so lange in gebrauch
ist und so lang testet ist wie die alten core utils in c also das was kaputt geht oder nicht
richtig funktioniert ist sogar in den rast tools höher als in den c plus in den c tools
Okay, Ecos war mal gleich.
Cross-Plattform ohne Schmerzen.
Okay, das lass ich mir gefallen.
Das lass ich mir gefallen.
Okay.
Wobei das auch nur ein ganz kleiner, sagen wir mal, Punkt ist, ja.
Weil ich glaube, die Anzahl der Leute, die Core-Utils irgendwie unter Windows installieren und nicht gleich WSL, dürfte doch ziemlich gering sein.
Aber okay, das ist ein Vorteil, lasse ich mir gefallen.
Ist okay.
Modernos Ökosystem, C-Code-Based, alt, schwer zu ändern, viele Leute fassen sie ungern an.
Ja gut, die funktioniert ja auch.
Ich behaupte mal, dass das die...
Also, ich habe das reingeguckt, ja, aber
ich behaupte mal, die C-Codebase von den
Coyotils ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir das finden.
Whoammer.c
Das ist jetzt auch nicht so wild.
Okay, das ist schon eklig.
Impressive.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht so wild.
Ich gebe zu, die Rust-Version ist schöner.
Performance-Concurrency.
Bei LS.
Okay, ja.
Aber macht das wirklich Sinn?
Teils ja, teils meh.
Ja.
Rewrite existiert nicht, weil jemand Langeweile hatte.
Doch. Doch. Ich behaupte,
ohne den Hintergrund zu erkennen,
behaupte ich mal,
der ursprüngliche Grund, warum jemand damit angefangen ist,
weil er Rust geil findet
und weil er Bock drauf hat.
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt Langeweile.
Doch. Ich glaube schon.
glaube schon ich glaube schon dass es ein großer faktor ist okay wenn du willst
kann ich dir auch sagen wann utils wirklich sinnvoll ist ok sollte ich mein
system auf die rust core utils umstellen oder bei den core bei den alten bleiben
Was?
Ah, yes.
Das ist schon sehr gut lesbar, oder?
If do V9?
Oder, oder
Possixly, correct?
Ja gut, du hast halt
40 Jahre Legacy-Zeug
da drin.
das okay das hast du bei der rastversion nicht das stimmt das stimmt das ist tatsächlich was
was für die rastversion spricht das hast du nicht ich halt was was will ich hier sehen
just echo go to just echo just echo okay das gebe ich zu das ist wirklich das ist wirklich
abwaggegliches auskommt
Zehntausend 16 plus hex to bin character obviously alles klar
Hat man wirklich irgendwo mal Performance-Probleme mit LS gehabt?
Selbst wenn du in dem Skript oft LS machst,
sollte es auf die Gesamtlaufzeit nicht viel Auswirkungen haben.
Naja.
Außer im High-Performance-Bash-Skripting
Das ist ein Wort, was ich mir gerade ausgedacht habe
Habe ich noch nie, glaube ich nicht, dass irgendjemand wirklich
So performance-kritische Sachen
Im Bash
Ja, ich gebe ja zu, es hat sicherlich
Gewisse Vorteile
Ob es das jetzt unbedingt braucht
Ich bin immer noch skeptisch, ja
Also was sagt ihr dann, ob ich umstellen soll
Ich erkläre dir das
Ohne Fanboy-Filter
kurz gesagt nein du solltest dein system noch nicht komplett auf rast umstellen bleibt bei
den knut hills auf deinem hauptsystem sind stabil und battle teste das habe ich ja auch gesagt ja
jedes skript erwartet genau dieses fall ist in de facto standards was gegen utility spricht
nicht 100 kompatibel reifegrad viele tools im system hängen die indirekt an wenn du das ersetzt
kann subtil chaos entsteht ok chat gpt denkt wieder geschichten aus in
container cross platform workflows übrigens container da ist halt einfach
das beste was es gibt ne go und dann scratch container oder
distroless container ist die bescheuerte bezeichnung überhaupt die basieren auf
debian weiß ich was daran ist es kost plattform experimentieren sicherheitskritische umgang mit
realist realistischen okay okay dann fragen wir mal warum stellt dann ubuntu ihr neues tls auf die
Rust, nenn ich TLS, LTS
auf die
Rust-Utils um.
Das wird
doch 100 pro Probleme
machen, oder?
Ja, ich sag ja gar nichts dagegen,
Icos, schnell ist immer besser, ne?
Das ist keine Frage. Aber
ja, das ist, dein Skript
läuft dann halt anstatt
anstatt 5 Sekunden
in 4,9 Sekunden.
So what?
Gute Frage.
Und hier lohnt es sich, ein Missverständnis
Ubuntu stellt nicht einfach
komplett auf Rust Core-Utils um.
Ach, machen sie nicht?
Was du wahrscheinlich gesehen hast, bezieht sich auf Testexperimente
und nicht auf einen harten Switch im nächsten LTS.
Moment, ist das nicht so?
Ja, sag ich doch.
Ich dachte, ich dachte eigentlich,
das nächste LTS...
Ja, genau, genau.
Das hab ich eigentlich auch gedacht,
dass in 1604, also in 2604,
das was jetzt kommt,
dass die das eigentlich umstellen wollten dachte ich eigentlich
genau ob und 16 04 replay system mit kohltieren rast implementations ok chat gibt keine ahnung
so was auch das gut perplexity perplexity sagt
implementierung praktische nutzen okay das habe ich kein bock was sagt denn die china
chinesen die schwätzt ja noch mehr als chat gpt sicherheit memory moderne werkzeuge war
bessere cross-plattform unterstützung modularität und wiederverwendbarkeit
lizenzierung test abdeckung und korrektheit
na dann komm scheiß drauf wir haben uns damit genug jetzt beschäftigt alles klar
rewrite written in rust blazingly fast
versuch mal die hier nee das reicht jetzt auch uns genug mit dem thema
beschäftigt du kannst du kannst als tipp du kannst mittlerweile hinzu open code
open code kann jlm das haben sie wieder umgestellt alter
Ich habe auch ein code in die eingerichtet auf der neuen kiste open code hat
Kostenloses glm
model drinnen
Wenn man das jetzt
also du kannst dort kostenlos das neueste glm verwenden mit open code
ja
ich glaube hier hinter steckt glm glm fünfpunkt wir müssen wir müssen mal kurz moment ich muss
mal kurz meine meine alte vor allem da hatte ich das noch offen dieses models was sie da haben das
ist glaube ich die lm 5.1
wartet mal ich hab das ich habe das hier noch nicht eingerichtet auf der anderen
kiste
dachte ich kann auch sein dass es das wieder umbenannt haben dass man die
öfters mal
Open code.
GLM 5.3 is not valid.
Okay.
Ja.
Aber ich glaube, Big Pickle ist GLM 5.1.
Ja, die sind
bei Open Code ist es auch so, dass es
manchmal langsam ist.
die free die free variante ist oftmals langsam können wir das neue video schon
auf 35 minuten da brauche ich da brauche ich ja ewig für ok ich nehme zwar ich nehme es mal auf
Ja, ging letztens ein bisschen durch die Newsseiten.
So, weiter hier.
Zack.
Zu.
So, dann gucken wir mal was.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie wohl...
Ach so, weil ich hier die Core-Utils gesehen habe, wurde ich etwas sidetracked.
Rust-Trended.
Exzellent. Wie viele...
Wie viele Sterne
hat mittlerweile eigentlich OpenClaw?
Boah!
Alter!
Vincent
Cock?
Besser Name.
TreeSitter.
Mistral
AS. AI.
Das kenn ich. Das ist irgend so ein
Sonntagshighlighting-Tool oder sowas, ne?
Den fand ich eigentlich ganz cool, bis ich festgestellt habe, dass das kein Svelte ordentlich highlighten kann.
Mal gucken, ob es das mittlerweile kann.
Docks.
Svelte.
Full Support.
Ja, Moment. Aber doch nicht.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Das stimmt nicht.
Das kann immer noch, glaube ich, kein Full...
Das kann nur die Script-Sachen highlighten.
Nicht HTML und CSS zusammen.
Naja, egal.
Müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken.
Wann machen wir Niri?
Ja, eigentlich wollte ich gestern Niri machen.
Das dauert aber eh 2-3 Streams insgesamt mit den ganzen Shells und so drumherum.
Aber mein Brain hat wieder nicht mitgespielt.
Vielleicht machen wir das heute Mittag.
RustFS.
Ah, das ist die Mini-Aero-Alternative.
Agent of Empires.
KI.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Syntax.
Highlighting Pager.
What?
Also hier haben wir Polar.
RS.
Query Engine for Data Frames written in Rust.
Polar
RS ist
analytical query engine written for...
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Was sind Data Frames?
Okay, Chat. Mag ja geiles Projekt sein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Delta.
Syntax Highlighting Pager
Forget Diff.
Gibt es da einen...
Ah.
Sonntag.
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Sonntags Highlighting in einem Diff und sowas.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Das ist eigentlich wirklich ganz cool.
Ja.
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Gibt es das denn hier für
Delta?
Useful Tool.
Ähm.
wie heißt das wie heißt das ding delta
x delta 3 geht delta das da oder geht geht delta auf 10 das ist das oder so tags vor geht and if
output
geht der pager based on delta but with the file tree
das ist ein diff nach
agitiv pager besser wird mit file tree alle ach so nicht das brauche ich nicht
ach hier hier ist das 7 so und wie benutzt man das jetzt kann ich jetzt
einfach sagen repos linux das kann man immer gut daran testen wenn es linux
source code funktioniert delta
ok das heißt ich sag jetzt hier in your get config jetzt konflikt pager delta
filter delta color only delta
ok dann lassen wir das mal
ZDF3. So, und jetzt kann ich sagen,
Git log minus
P1 zum Beispiel.
Ne.
Ich muss wirklich Git div verwenden,
ja.
Git div
head
mit
Okay, das zu...
Es scheint zu funktionieren.
Okay.
Head mit
Head 1 zurück. Dürfen wir mal.
Okay.
Hm.
Das ist in der Tat echt
cool.
Das gefällt mir
eigentlich ganz gut, muss ich euch jetzt
mal ehrlich sagen.
Ja, Rot ist entfernt.
Gehe ich mal stark von aus.
Grün ist hinzugefügt.
Und es ist Highlight.
Es ist Highlighted.
Das finde ich gar...
Leute, was sagt ihr dazu?
Das finde ich gar nicht mal so richtig.
Probieren wir das mal von meinen Dingern aus.
Da haben wir ja gerade noch nicht wirklich was.
Coyotils.
Machen wir mal.
Blazingly Fast.
Ja, hier kann man es besser erkennen.
Das finde ich in der Tat
echt ganz cool eigentlich.
Ich glaube, das werde ich mal so lassen.
Das werde ich, glaube ich, mal so lassen.
Und mal gucken, wie mir das in Zukunft so gefällt.
Sieht man hier auch, welche Datei editiert wurde? Ja, removed.
In der Tat.
Das finde ich gut. Das gefällt mir.
Ich meine, wie man nicht GITDIF, sondern wie du DELTA findest. Oder wie ihr dieses Highlighting
findet. Ja, ja, das ist DELTA. Das ist ein Syntax Highlighter for pager for GITDIF.
was für crepe
ach play output geht auch okay wie moment wie darf ich mir das bei crepe vorstellen
gut ja das benutzt jetzt delta das heißt du siehst hier was hinzugefügt wurde was entfernt
wurde. Und in Source-Code-Abschnitten
siehst du
auch Syntax-Highlighting.
Was ich sehr cool finde, ehrlich gesagt.
Das gefällt mir, das hat was.
Okay, Git-Blame.
Read-Me oder so.
Uuh!
Okay, das ist gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Da finde ich den
nackten Git-Blame
irgendwie besser.
Das ist
gewöhnungsbedürftig aber nutzt man geht auch mit überhaupt wirklich im termin na klar geht
termin ist das einzig wahre leute idee ist paint job terminal holy
ach komm mal geht lockt geht lockt funktioniert auch okay probieren wir noch mal was aus ich
meine das ernst also ich verwende geht nur auf der kommando zeile nur ausschließlich
und ich halte überhaupt nichts von ide plugins
naja aber dass man da so tags highlighting hat ist ja an sich schon mal nicht verkehrt
ist ja an sich schon mal nicht schlecht eigentlich.
Okay, wie gesagt, es gibt zwei Dinger, wozu ich GUI-Tools bei Git sinnig finde
und man die auch durchaus verwenden kann.
Das ist für DIVs, also für Merch-Konflikte, DIVs und für History-Crafts.
Aber ansonsten...
Terminal ist beste, weil Terminal-Git-Command die Wahrheit ist.
Du weißt genau, was es macht und nicht, wie ich das mal bei einem unserer Java-Entwickler gesehen habe,
der immer leere Commits committed hat, weil er nicht wusste, wie er sein E-Git verwenden soll in Eclipse.
Commandline ist einzig wahre.
Das finde ich aber jetzt, die Ansicht finde ich an sich jetzt auch nicht.
Aber man kommt auch mit dem
Merch-Konflikt-View
in Git auf der Kommando-Zeile.
Also für 95% aller Merch-Konflikte
kommt man damit gut klar.
Was macht euer Azubi gerade?
Der ist fertig.
Also ich muss sagen,
Delta, das gefällt mir. Das hat was.
Im Chat scheinen sie auch zugefallen.
Das muss ich mir merken.
Das muss ich nochmal irgendwie hier hin kopieren.
So.
Always show.
Was ich da dran denke.
Was habe ich denn da auf?
Demo Pyrrha.
Was war das?
Nichts, was ich brauche.
Delete.
Irgendeine Sache, die ich irgendwann mal gespeichert habe.
wobei wir können ja hier eigentlich
only show on it.
Reicht doch.
Aber das finde ich gut. Das hat was.
Siehst du mal, Leute, es hat sich mal
wieder gelohnt. Selten,
aber es kommt in letzter Zeit
selten vor. Aber es kommt in letzter Zeit vor.
Wir haben was in den GitHub-Trends gefunden,
was ich gut finde.
Und das Beste ist halt,
das ändert an den eigentlichen
Git-Kommandos nichts. Ich kann das hier genauso gut
auf dem Server ausführen. Das ist halt das normale
Git-Diff. Aber bei mir lokal
halt besser, weil man besser durchblickt.
Das finde ich, also Delta ist nice.
Das gefällt mir schon mal.
So, Rust, jetzt gucken wir als letztes nochmal,
was bei C-Sharp
noch so brennt. S-Box,
Game Engine,
gibt es jetzt, das ist quasi der Nachfolger
von Garry's Mod.
Songs.
Avalonia.
Media Player for Language Learning.
Aha.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Roblox.
Links Awakening?
DX HD?
Oder? Was?
Was heißt? Was ist das?
Was bin ich sehend?
LATX HD
Das haben die hingeschrieben, dass Nintendo
die nicht gleich takedownt.
Wie darf ich mir das vorstellen jetzt?
Wie sieht das aus?
Hey Leute, willkommen zurück im Videobereich...
Ah! Ah! Ah!
Ich will es leiser machen!
Moment, das...
Das ist jetzt die HD-Variante?
Ich meine, es passt mehr drauf als auf dem Gameboy.
Ah, das ist die HD-Variante, okay.
Weil die so, ja gut, ist halt deutlich größer als auf dem Gameboy, ne?
Ja, es sieht schon eine ganze Ecke besser aus.
Aha, was sich alles gibt.
So, was trennt sonst noch? Unity oder was auch immer. Little Big Mouse. DPI Aware Mouse Move
across screens.
Zwei, two years ago, aber
trendet. Okay.
So. Uno.
Und die, ach,
die ganzen ARR-Programme.
Und das, keine Ahnung, was es ist.
China, China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Wollen wir uns das mal translaten lassen.
Hier haben wir Chrome.
Wie translate man in Firefox
gescheit geht das nicht auch ich mache das unsere baukram habt ihr eine ahnung
wie man wie man firefox translate hat wie das funktioniert
wir müssen eh installieren weiß gar nicht warum kommen installiert
chromium
oben rechts im bürgermenü translate page ok translate from ach das kann das nicht
mehr automatisch erkennen okay ist der okay chrome chrome ist da viel besser
Geh weg, geh weg, KDE Wallet.
Piss dich, Alter.
Äh, Chrome, hallo?
Chrome?
Nein.
Geh weg, geh weg.
KDE Wallet.
Okay, so, jetzt hier, Translate.
Translate to English.
Billy, Billy.
Downloader for the Bilibili Website
Also quasi China YouTube
Okay, China YouTube Download
Wie sieht dann eigentlich
Okay, okay
Wie sieht denn eigentlich
Bilibili, ich war noch nie auf Bilibili
Wie sieht Bilibili aus
Kann man das aufmachen
Ohne, dass man Angst haben muss
Dass irgendwelche Sachen gleich
Erscheinen, die mich
Gebannt werden lassen auf Twitch
Ich mache jetzt mal Billy Billy auf.
Okay.
Okay, es sieht ja nicht nach MonkaTos aus.
Okay, das ist Billy Billy.
Chinakinesen-YouTube.
Das ist auf jeden Fall was für die ganzen Fans unter uns.
Ah, Billy Billy.
genug billy billy gut chat jetzt wissen wir schon mal was trendet auf github und
es war eine coole sache dabei war schon eine ganze weile nicht mehr vorgekommen
ist finde ich sehr nice rpg ja ja ja moment das ist ein offizielles twitch
emotes das gibt es mittlerweile
linus tech tipps ist auf billy billy kann mir durchaus vorstellen ja der muss
er gucken dass er nichts anbrennt es ist dann mit translation ins chinesische
was ist nochmal post post ist noch mal im chat
was haben wir dann sonst noch irgendwas übersehen
Was ist Niri?
Ein Window Manager
Ein Scrollable Tiling Window Manager
Ich kann das doch hier nicht aufmachen
Post einfach den Videolink
Das Ding kenne ich nicht.
Den kenne ich nicht.
Wir probieren Niri aus.
Das scheint auch so ein bisschen das Hype-Ding aktuell zu sein.
Videolink wurde runtergenommen.
Ja, da können wir es doch auch nicht mehr gucken.
Verstehe ich nicht.
I don't know.
Oder meins im Discord ist es noch verfügbar.
Okay, Moment.
Achso, ja gut, hier bin ich nicht eingeloggt.
Dann kann ich höchstens später mal reingucken.
Das geht jetzt on stream gerade nicht.
So.
Ja, Chat, gab es diese Woche sonst noch
irgendwelche wichtigen Dinger, die wir besprechen müssen?
Bevor wir uns ein paar
YouTube-Videos angucken.
Oh.
Ich bin müde immer noch ein bisschen.
Wobei, geht eigentlich.
Eigentlich bin ich gar nicht so müde.
Gestern schön 9 Kilometer gerannt.
Haben wir uns vorhin schon ein Video zu angeguckt.
Ich habe es nicht so hundertprozentig gecheckt.
Gestern 9 Kilometer gerannt.
Relativ gemächlich.
Ich glaube, ungefähr 6,30er Pace.
Und ich merke, dass ich mittlerweile echt wieder eine ganze Ecke fitter bin.
Weil ich merke so gut wie nichts mehr in den Beinen.
Und mir tut auch kein Schienbein weh und sowas.
Wann machen wir Niri?
Ich wollte Niri eigentlich gestern machen, hat aber nicht geklappt.
Vielleicht heute Mittag, ich weiß es noch nicht genau.
Du hattest drei Bewerbungsgespräche und wie lief's?
Bankreich stellt auf Linux um. Das habe ich gelesen.
6,30, 9 Kilometer ist doch nicht...
Naja.
Also das ist vielleicht...
Sagen wir mal so, wenn du frisch anfängst,
dann ist das relativ,
sehr zügig, ja.
Dann packst du das nicht. Das hätte ich auch nicht
gepackt, auch vor ein paar Jahren.
Aber ich habe jetzt ja kaum was
gemacht und kriege das
locker hin. Also es ist
schon
nicht sonderlich schnell, jetzt aktuell.
Wie hoch geht dein Puls? Ich habe keine
Smartwatch mehr an.
Das hat mich übelst gestresst,
das permanente
Puls kontrollieren und Ruhepuls daheim
kontrollieren. Ich zeichne jetzt nur noch
auf mit meinem Handy.
Ich starte einfach eine Aktivität auf
Komoot und zeichne auf.
Ich überprüfe
keinen Puls mehr.
Das hat mich zu sehr gestresst.
Warten auf Sicherheitsupdate.
Angreifer reagieren. Was?
Attackieren, nicht reagieren.
Die Solarförderung soll abgeschafft werden
Wenn du deine Anlage willst
musst du das noch vor 2027 machen
Das ist mir egal
Mach ich wahrscheinlich eh nicht
Angreifer nutzen derzeit eine Zero-Day-Sicherheit
im Adobe Reader
Seriously, Leute
Ich glaube, ich hab seit 15 Jahren
keinen Adobe Reader mehr installiert
Boah, ey
Das ist aber echt heftig
Wie alt bist du?
Also ich komm auf
190 oder so, aber das geht
Das geht, wenn ich volle Pulle
2 Minuten berghoch
renne oder so, bis zum
Anschlag, oder ein paar Minuten
berghoch, aber da bin ich
dead, wenn ich, also
Ja, ja, das ist, das ist ja auch okay.
Das ist ja auch okay.
Das sollte halt nicht unbedingt Durchschnitt sein, ne?
Also, das ist schon okay.
Gibt Leute, die haben bis 200, 210 oder so.
Ne, ne, das ist kein Ding.
Ja, würde ich ganz ehrlich, ähm, 195, das ist, wenn man diese, wenn man das so in Zonen einteilt,
dann ist das so diese 105% oder was es so gibt, diese Sache, diese Dinger, diese Belastung, die man eigentlich maximal 10 Sekunden halten soll oder so.
Aber du schaffst das. Ich kann dir sagen, wenn du regelmäßig laufen gehst, wirst du ganz schnell besser werden.
Also ich kann es nur von mir berichten, ja, also es ging relativ schnell der Progress zu einem 6er Pace. 6er Pace bedeutet 5km in der halben Stunde oder 10km in der Stunde. Das ging relativ schnell.
relativ schnell heißt also das kann man quasi so in einem jahr oder so kann man das gut schaffen
wenn man wirklich regelmäßig dran bleibt und jeden tag laufen geht man mit einem tag pause
vielleicht aber zwei tagen pausen wenn andere schienbein weh tut was bei mir auch super war
ist wenn wir das schienbein wehgetan hat oder die wade wehgetan hat dann bin ich an dem tag
fahrrad gefahren weil das noch mal ganz anders belastet als das bein man muss aber schon
regelmäßig jeden tag mit meiner kurzen pause muss man schon dran bleiben und
wenn man das wenn man das im jahr lang macht dann schafft man denke dann
schafft man ganz guten 6er pace würde ich jetzt einfach mal so von mir aus
sagen nach welchem schema hast du trainiert
hat es speziell anhalter von irgendwem naja ich habe mich ein bisschen ich habe
mich ein bisschen mit beschäftigt somit youtube videos und ich habe meine gamen
uhr bzw mit der gamen app und trainingsplan erstellen lassen
Das war dann immer eine Mischung aus einmal die Woche Long Run, dann mal Tempo Run, da mal Intervall Runs, da mal Recovery Run.
Also das kann ich tatsächlich echt empfehlen, wenn du dir eine Garmin Uhr kaufst oder halt eine Fitnessuhr, aber bei Garmin weiß ich, dass das ganz gut ist.
Und dir den Trainingsplan mit der Garmin App unter Uhr erstellen lässt. Das fand ich persönlich ganz gut.
Ich mache es jetzt aktuell gerade ohne Garmin-Uhr, weil mich das echt sehr gestresst hat.
Mit dem, mit dem.
Aber ihr wisst auch, ich habe ja eine, so eine, wie nennt man das jetzt mittlerweile?
Eine Angsterkrankung nennt man das ja.
Ich sage immer Angststörung, was Krankheiten und Gesundheitssachen angeht.
und ich habe gemerkt, also ich mache mir teilweise
super krass Gedanken, wegen
irgendwelchen
Wehwehchen, wo andere drüber lachen, ja
und
ich habe gemerkt, dass mich das einfach super
krass stresst, wenn ich
meinen Ruhepuls und Puls kontrolliere
weil ich dann tausend Sachen
reininterpretiere, so
hier, Ruhepuls von
musst dich gleich untersuchen
lassen, das ist viel zu hoch
richtig hängen geblieben, Alter.
Andere haben einen Ruhepuls von 90,
weil es zu fett sind.
Und juckt keinen, ja.
Ein Ruhepuls von 70
ist okay, ja.
Also ich hab einen Ruhepuls,
also wenn ich wirklich mal entspannt bin,
von, glaub, 56 oder so.
Übrigens, Fun Fact,
Jan Ulrich,
der Radsportler,
der hatte angeblich
einen Ruhepuls von
ich glaube
42 oder so.
Als er Tour de France gefahren ist.
Und noch krasser
kennt ihr Marco Pantani,
das war auch ein Radsportler,
der ist gestorben
an einer Überdosis Drogen
und der hat halt auch gedopt ohne Ende.
Und der hatte mal in einem Interview erzählt,
oder das wurde berichtet darüber,
dass der, glaube ich, einen Ruhepuls von,
ich glaube, 36 oder 35 hatte.
Und das Krasse bei dem war,
er hat sich so viel Doping reingehauen.
Also das wurde ja damals mit Epo gedopt.
Das heißt, du hattest, also unter der Haube hieß das,
deine roten Blutkörperchen,
du hattest mehr rote Blutkörperchen,
mehr rote Blutkörperchen, die konnten
dann quasi, konnte dein Blut mehr Sauerstoff
aufnehmen. Das Problem dadurch
war aber halt, das Blut
war viel dickflüssiger. So,
und der hat erzählt,
der hat einen Ruhepuls von, ich sag jetzt irgendwie
35, 36 gehabt nachts
und der hatte ein Warngerät,
der hatte permanent einen Pulschecker
und wenn sein Puls unter 40 oder so
gegangen ist, musste der nachts
aufstehen und rumlaufen,
weil er sonst ein sehr hohes
Schlaganfallrisiko
hatte und Herzinfarktrisiko.
Na,
nur, nur wenn du die krasses
Dopingzeug reinhaust, ja?
Der hatte halt so dickes Blut,
weil er halt gedopt
hatte, er ist fuck,
dass er nachts aufstehen musste und rumlaufen
musste, weil er sonst einen Schlaganfall kriegt.
Das ist schon, das ist schon
echt keck weight oder also das ist übertrieben
ich denke mal wenn du dich nicht dobst ja da kannst du wahrscheinlich gar nicht
so ein ruhepuls beziehungsweise ist dein blut ja auch nicht so dick dann ist ein
ruhe das problem ist ja ein ruhepuls an sich wenn du trainiert bist der ist
natürlich niedriger, dein Herz pumpt ja auch mehr.
Das ist dann gar nicht so schlimm.
Aber wenn du halt
Blutkonsistenz
von
irgendwie Kartoffelbrei
hast, weil du so viel rote
Blutkörperchen hast, dann ist es halt
natürlich schlecht.
Das ist schön zu hören.
Ja, bei mir ist auch viel besser geworden, so das letzte Jahr über schon.
Oder sagen wir mal so, ich habe das ja erst seit einem Jahr oder seit...
Ein bisschen über einem Jahr.
Knapp ein Jahr.
Aber das letzte halbe Jahr, das ist auch richtig, richtig viel besser geworden.
Das ist bei mir auch so.
Ja.
Aber es freut mich zu hören, dass es bei dir gut ist.
Ich denke, bei mir wird auch...
Es ist jetzt auch schon besser.
Es dauert halt ein bisschen, ne?
Genau, aber das kann ich dir echt empfehlen, so eine Fitnessuhr.
Du hast einen 39er Ruhepuls ohne Doping, nicht schlecht.
39er Ruhepuls, da musst du aber hier die super krasse Sportskanone sein.
Oder du nimmst Beta-Blocker oder sowas, was den Puls senkt.
Aber ansonsten ist 39 extrem niedrig.
egal genug gesundheitsthemen ist das nervt mich sie war stresst mich deswegen ziehe ich mir auch
keine fitness nur mehr an du willst gar nicht unbedingt einen niedrigen ruhepuls du kriegst
automatisch niedrigen ruhepuls weil dein herz kreislauf system besser funktioniert und mehr
pumpt mehr mehr sauerstoff pumpt wenn du trainiert bist du kannst ja gar nichts
gegen machen und an sich ist natürlich ein richtiger rupels auch insgesamt gut
ja was weiß ich herzinfarkt risiko und sonst was aber alles unter keine ahnung
90 oder so ist okay bei frauen glaube ich potenziell ein bisschen höher ich
Ich glaube, bei Frauen sagt man so bis 90 und bei Männern...
Nee, ich glaube, insgesamt ist bis 90 Ruhepuls ist okay.
Alles drüber ist zu schnell.
Bei Männern ist es meistens unter 80 und bei Männern ist es meistens unter 70.
Bei Frauen, glaube ich, meistens unter 80, aber unter 90...
Und nee, bei Männern ist es meistens unter 80 und bei Frauen ist es meistens unter 90.
Irgendwie so, fragt mich nicht genau.
Täglich Radfahren Mountainbiken, ja.
Ja, das bringt richtig was.
Also wie gesagt, was bei mir, nochmal zurück zu dem...
Genau.
Das ist einfach für die Gesundheit gut.
Also nochmal eine Sache hier zurück.
Also was bei mir wirklich geholfen hat, ist regelmäßig laufen gehen.
Wie ist der Puls bei C++ programmieren?
Oh, da müsste ich mir mal meine Uhr anziehen.
Da habe ich bestimmt einen Puls von 130 oder so, weil es mich so aufregt.
Also was bei mir geholfen hat, ist diese automatische Trainingsplan-Generierung mit Garmin
Das fand ich echt gut
Und was echt wichtig ist, regelmäßig
Also, es ist viel besser, wenn, sagen wir mal, jemand fängt an, ja
Wenn man anfängt, kann man nicht von 0 auf 100 laufen gehen, weil da fallen einem die Beine ab nach 1-2 Wochen, ja
Also wenn man jetzt gar nichts gewohnt ist und geht jetzt einfach 7 Tage die Woche rennen
weil man denkt, ey, jetzt muss richtig ran, dann kann man ab der dritten Woche nicht mehr laufen, gescheit.
Also das muss man nicht übertreiben.
Aber sagen wir mal, jemand fängt an und du hast zwei Leute, du hast zwei Leute, die fangen jetzt an mit regelmäßig Laufen gehen
oder man kann das sicherlich auch auf Fahrrad fahren oder sowas oder schwimmen oder so übertragen.
Du hast zwei Leute, einer fängt an, der rennt die Woche zweimal bis zum Umfallen für eine, keine Ahnung,
Solange wie er kann bis zum Umfallen zweimal die Woche.
Versus einer, der rennt viermal die Woche, aber dreimal entspannt und einmal so, dass er es gut aushält.
Was meint ihr, wer nach einem halben Jahr trainierter ist?
Oder bessere Zeiten packt?
Ich tippe eindeutig auf den, der viermal laufen geht.
Und nicht der, der zweimal bis zum Umfallen rennen geht.
Die Masse macht's.
Die Masse macht es da wirklich.
Und man muss gar nicht bis zum Umfallen rennen.
Also du musst gar nicht rennen, bis du immer einen Puls von 195 hast.
Also als ich noch meine Garmin-Uhr angezogen habe, hatte ich einen Puls von irgendwie 150 oder sowas.
Wenn ich normale Geschwindigkeit gerannt bin.
Oder auch mal deutlich weniger, wenn ich super entspannt gerannt bin.
Aber so meistens irgendwas um 150
154 oder irgendwie sowas
Ich hab doch auf
Ich hab doch sogar hier ab und zu mal
Als ich die Uhr, als ich die Garmin Uhr
Noch regelmäßig angezogen hab
Hab ich doch ab und zu
Auch mal
Ähm
Hier gepostet, guck hier
so 154
achso das war also ich denke noch da habe ich auch drei bis vier monate
nichts mehr gemacht das vielleicht ist nicht so aussagekräftig 15 kilometer 6
36er pace 151 im durchschnitt 1200 kalorien weg gerannt also die also 50
die 15 Kilometer Runde bin ich schon lange
nicht mehr, bin ich schon lange nicht mehr gelaufen.
Müsste ich...
Heute wäre eigentlich ein guter Tag dafür.
Nicht so warm.
Sonntag, nicht viel los.
Ja, ich hab die...
Ich hab das letzte Jahr...
Das lag aber auch an meiner Angststörung.
Ich hab das letzte Jahr über nicht so viel gemacht.
Guck, da sieht man hier gleich wieder
hochgegangen.
Ja, ich habe auch wieder ein bisschen zugenommen.
Ja.
Hier war ich, hier war ich relativ fit.
Das war, das war hier ganz gut.
Ja.
13 Kilometer.
6,15er Pace, 150.
150. Da war ich, also da so vor eineinhalb Jahren, da war ich echt ganz, ganz gut dabei. Und eigentlich war mein Ziel zum damaligen Zeitpunkt, ich möchte es nächstes Jahr schaffen, 5 Kilometer mit einem Fünfer-Pace zu rennen.
Das Problem war, dass ich dann, dass es quasi hier so Ende des Jahres, Ende 2024 hat das so angefangen mit meiner Angstproblematik da, wegen den bescheuertsten Umständen, will ich jetzt gar nicht drüber reden.
Und ab da habe ich halt immer so Phasen gehabt, wo ich teilweise ein paar Monate gar nichts gemacht habe.
Deswegen hat es halt sehr stark stagniert.
Ich würde sagen, ich bin jetzt ungefähr ein bisschen schlechter als auf dem Niveau.
Also eine ganze Ecke schlechter.
Also wenn ich das jetzt rennen würde, würde ich das wahrscheinlich mit 630er Pace rennen und ein bisschen höherem Puls.
Also so fit bin ich noch nicht.
So, das ist eigentlich mein Ziel.
Und das würde ich jetzt echt gerne mal schaffen, nachdem ich jetzt ja meine Gehirnsache halbwegs im Griff habe.
Mit ab und zu ein paar Ausrutschern.
Ich muss rutschern, bin ich jetzt wieder regelmäßig am Rennen und ich versuche tatsächlich jeden Tag laufen zu gehen und immer mal ein Tag Pause zu machen. Ich wechsle halt ab zwischen entspannt rennen, schneller rennen, auch mal wirklich 8x10 Sekunden sprinten und sowas.
Ne, ne, zweimal die Woche ist zu wenig.
Also ich kann dir echt empfehlen, mach nicht zweimal die Woche volle Pulle.
Mach lieber viermal die Woche.
Und dann unterschiedlich.
Also man sagt ja in der Regel so, Noobs wie wir, wir sollen 80-20 trainieren.
Das bedeutet 80% Low Intensity, 20% High Intensity.
Profis machen eher 90-10%.
Also sprich 90% Low Intensity, 10% High Intensity.
Das liegt aber einfach daran, weil Profis ein viel größeres Trainingspensum haben.
Also mach auf jeden Fall mehr, aber dafür verausgab dich nicht jedes Mal, weil sonst packst du nicht mehr.
Mach einfach dreimal die Woche ganz entspannt und einmal die Woche zackig.
Und wenn du es richtig gut machen willst, dann machst du es mit einem Plan,
So dass du zum Beispiel sagst, okay, wir machen einmal am Wochenende eine lange Runde, also quasi so eine Stunde 15, eine Stunde 30, dafür wirklich gemäßig und dafür lang, aber nicht so anstrengend.
Dann machst du einmal die Woche ordentlich zackig, am besten noch mit ein paar Mal Intervall sprinten dazwischen und dann machst du einen Recovery Run und dann machst du noch zweimal die Woche so semi-schnelles Tempo und dann wirst du sehr schnell sehr, sehr viel besser werden.
Gut, Job habe ich auch, Kind habe ich nicht.
Was bei mir tatsächlich ganz gut funktioniert ist, wenn man Homeoffice machen kann.
Weiß ich nicht, wie das bei dir aussieht.
Wenn man Homeoffice machen kann, finde ich es ganz gut.
Und wenn morgens noch nicht viel los ist, gehe ich ganz gerne nochmal eine Runde rennen, bevor die ganze Meeting-Geschichte anfängt.
Unter der Woche, wenn ich nach Frankfurt fahre, ist es tatsächlich ein bisschen schwieriger, weil da bin ich immer so kaputt.
Aber ich zwinge mich dann trotzdem zu, ein paar Runden immer noch die Woche abends zu rennen.
Eine Sache, die man sich denken muss, ist, man merkt ja, dass das gut für einen ist.
und man muss das so sehen, wie wenn man Pillen nimmt.
Ja, keiner nimmt gerne Pillen, aber wenn man merkt, dass die Pillen einem helfen,
dann nimmt man auch Pillen, obwohl man keinen Bock drauf hat.
So, und ich meine jetzt nicht Doping, oder so.
Also ich meine jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn man irgendeine Krankheit hat und merkt, okay, Pillen helfen einem.
Keiner nimmt gerne Pillen, aber man nimmt sie trotzdem, weil man merkt, sie helfen.
Das heißt, man kann auch Sport machen, wenn man keinen Bock hat, weil man merkt, es bringt richtig was, es hilft was.
Und nachdem man Sport gemacht hat, bringt es ja oftmals den ganzen restlichen Tag was.
Wird mehr Dopamin produziert, hat man über ganzen Tagen mehr Dopamin im Gehirn und das bringt was.
Das heißt, man kann das so ein bisschen sehen, wie man nimmt Medikamente gegen eine Krankheit.
Kann man auch sagen, man macht, auch wenn man keinen Bock hat, mindestens mal eine halbe Stunde Sport am Tag, weil es insgesamt halt einfach was bringt.
Hast du was mit? Nö, nö. Ich supplemente nix. Das brauchen wir.
Ganz ehrlich, bei unserem Fitnessstand brauchen wir keine Supplements oder irgendwas, bin ich der Meinung.
Brauchen wir nicht.
ja irgendwelche krassen sportler dudes okay das einzige was ich mache ist ich
nehme alle paar jogging runden also tage nämlich löse ich mir eine magnesium
tablette auf und trinkt das so jeden 1 alle 1 bis 2 tage wenn ich sport gemacht
habe wie gesagt trinke ich trinke ich so eine brause magnesium brausetablette
das ist auch das einzige was ich mache ansonsten futter ich ganz normal wenn
ich nicht normal futtern würde würde ich wahrscheinlich noch deutlich
besser abnehmen.
Nö, mach ich nicht. Kein extra Protein oder
irgendwas. Ich fress mein Zeug
ganz normal. Ich müsste, ich müsste
eigentlich noch ein bisschen mehr aufs Essen achten.
Dann, ähm,
dann würde ich auch deutlich besser noch
abnehmen, trotz Sport. Weil da gibt's
doch diesen Spruch, you can never outrun
your diet.
Ja, ich,
also,
ähm,
ich fress zu viel, auch mit Sport, ja.
Zucker ist nicht verkehrt
Was ich mache mittlerweile ist
Ich hab ne ganze Weile, bevor ich joggen gegangen bin
Gerade mittags, ja, wenn das Mittagessen schon ne Weile her ist
Also es ist fatal
Wenn man losläuft schon mit Hunger
Das klappt meistens nicht gut
Oder auf Fahrrad fahren
Also was ich ne ganze Weile gemacht hab, ich hab so Schokobrötchen
Vom Lidl oder so gefuttert
So Dinger hier, ja
Hab ich immer gegessen
So Sachen hier, hab ich immer 1, 2 gefuttert
bevor ich losgerannt bin.
Mittlerweile esse ich Zwieback mit Banane drauf.
Äh, nein, sowas.
Igitt ist das eklig, Alter.
Boah, das sieht zum Kotzen aus.
Ich...
Alter, das sieht aus, als hätte ich gebrochen, Mann.
Also, ich nehme mir zwei Zwieback
und mache Scheiben,
mache jeweils fünf Scheiben Bananen drauf
und die esse ich davor.
Das ist, das finde ich, Bananen in Scheiben drauf, ja.
Ich esse zwei Zwieback mit Bananen in Scheiben drauf und das gibt mir genug Power für meine tägliche Runde.
Äh, das mache ich nicht. Zuckerlösung spülen und solche Dinger, auch Gels und so, mache ich nicht,
weil wusstet ihr, dass ein Großteil der Profi-Radsportler Zahnprobleme hat?
weil die den ganzen Tag Zuckerzeug futtern ohne Zähneputzen.
Das ist keine allzu gute Idee.
Wo das sinnvoll ist, ist wenn man, sagen wir jetzt mal,
eine 3, 4, 5, 6 Stunden Ausfahrt macht,
dann ist es sicherlich sinnvoll,
sich ein bisschen Kohlenhydrat-Krams in sein Trinken zu mischen und sowas alles.
Für die normalen Jogging-Einlagen braucht man das meiner Meinung nach nicht.
Das Einzige, was ich habe, ist, ich habe so ein paar Riegel.
Ich habe so...
Moment.
Muss mal bei Amazon gucken.
Das ist so ein Set, habe ich immer.
So Limone und...
Wie heißen die denn?
Nee, nee, nee, das ist es nicht.
Das ist es nicht.
Da habe ich immer ein, zwei Riegel dabei,
wenn ich Wochenende
Long Run mache.
So von eine Stunde, 20.
Hm.
Wie hießen die Dinger denn?
Raw Bites
Ja, davon habe ich so ein Set
Kaufe ich mir ab und zu mal
Raw Bites Riegel
Das sind die, genau
Die hier
Die esse ich ganz gern
Da gibt es so ein Probier-Set
Probierbox
Oder auch nicht
Gibt es nicht mehr? Gab es mal.
Da sind alle möglichen drin.
Robots, ja.
Ja, sowas hier.
Nein, danke.
Alle Riegel.
Probierbox, genau.
Probierbox, elf Riegel.
So ein Ding
kaufe ich mir ab und zu mal
und stecke mir ein, zwei Riegel ein,
aber auch nur, wenn ich eine größere Runde rennen gehe oder wenn ich ein paar Stunden Fahrrad fahren gehe.
So, und das Letzte, was mir auch noch geholfen hat, ist, wenn ich es manchmal mit Rennen übertrieben habe
und mir das Schienbein oder die Wade oder sowas wehgetan hat, dann bin ich meistens diesen Tag,
wenn Sport dran war, weil manchmal muss man auch mal eine Pause machen, bin ich dann ein bisschen Fahrrad fahren gegangen.
Das hat auch geholfen, weil dann hat man keinen Eideltag, aber kann seine Beine ein bisschen ausruhen.
So, aber genug Sport-Talk.
So sieht's aus.
So, dann gehen wir mal auf YouTube.
Empfehlung für Schuhe oder Klamotten.
Okay, muss ich noch machen.
Habe ich meine Schuhe, die ich habe.
Asics.
Gel.
Nimbus.
20 sind das die neuen.
Ich glaube schon.
Also,
die Schuhe habe ich,
aber
ich habe die in extra
weit.
Gibt es eigentlich 29
schon?
Nee, 28.
Extra
weit.
Findet man teilweise
gar nicht, weil ich habe
sehr breite Füße.
ja also manchmal manchmal findet man da findet man die dinger bei amazon
Ja, nehmen wir mal hier 3 extra weit. Gibt es das vielleicht in irgendeiner Art? Also die habe ich.
in extra weit.
Kostet ein bisschen was, ja.
Aber
die sind top.
Die sind top.
Falls du auch
ein bisschen schwerer bist,
also wenn du jetzt nicht so ein super Leichtgewicht bist,
also ich wiege aktuell ein bisschen über 80 Kilo,
bei 1,74
Also ich bin ein bisschen schwerer.
Und da sind so Dämpfungsschuhe top.
Weil damit kannst du halt auch 4-5 mal oder kannst auch 6 mal die Woche damit rennen, ohne dass dir die Beine abfallen.
Lass dir nichts erzählen von irgendwelchen Sportgeschäften, dass die coolen Leute Schuhe mit Carbonplatte rennen oder sowas.
Das ist alles Schwachsinn.
Das ist was für Leute, die Rennen laufen wollen oder halt ihre Bestzeit knacken wollen.
Aber nix für das tägliche, wir laufen unsere Runde.
Da sind so Dämpfungsschuhe viel besser.
Also die kann ich dir empfehlen.
Und für Klamotten, ganz ehrlich, das Wichtigste, was ich für mich entdeckt habe, sind Unterhosen mit so Sportunterhosen.
Weil die normalen Unterhosen, die saugen sich halt super schnell voll mit Schwitzen.
So Sportunterhosen, so quasi so Funktionsunterhosen, das ist das Einzige, was ich da empfehlen kann.
Ansonsten kannst du anziehen, was du willst.
Ja, so Funktionsklamotten sind nicht verkehrt, weil ansonsten werden die Klamotten schnell vollgeschwitzt.
Und ich persönlich, das ist aber echt eine Geschmacksfrage,
ich persönlich lauf gerne mit kurzer hose und kurzen und kurzem t shirt auch
wenn es ein bisschen kühler ist umgedreht gibt es welche wenn es da
nicht super heiß ist randy mit langen klamotten also ich ich laufe viel lieber
mit kurzen und sei es lange lange lange
langem oberteil und kurzer hose ich laufe einfach viel viel lieber mit
kurzer hose als mit langer hose
Ja, also Schuhe ganz ohne Dämpfung, wenn du längere Strecken läufst und gerade wenn du nicht so gübt bist und gerade vielleicht wenn du ein bisschen schwerer bist, das ist nix.
Da tut dir nach ein paar Tagen so krass das Bein weh, das finde ich nicht sinnig.
Also das Wichtigste ist aber ohne Mist, wenn du regelmäßig rennen gehst, finde ich Schuhe mit Dämpfung.
Musst du mal gucken, dass du welche findest, die dir gut passen und die dir ein gutes Gefühl hast am Fuß.
Ich habe die hier, kann ich empfehlen, von ASICS, Gel Nimbus 28.
Ob du die jetzt in normal, weit oder extra weit brauchst, kommt ein bisschen auf deinen Fuß an.
So, jetzt haben wir es aber alles durch hier.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, was gibt es denn auf YouTube so
Also das Morpheus Video
Können wir
Nicht gucken
Das 35 Minuten, wenn ich ein 35 Minuten Video
Mir angucke und reacte
Dann wisst ihr genau, das dauert eineinhalb Stunden
Maxke, wie gefällt dir das Buch?
Super, aber ich habe immer noch nicht
Großartig weiter gehört
Aber den Anfang fand ich super nice
Ich hab aber noch nicht weiter gehört
Das Ding ist, wenn mich mal was gehuckt hat, weiß ich genau
Ich hör das komplett durch
Und das will ich gerade aktuell noch nicht
Welches Buch? Dungeon Crawler Carl
Ich hör mir das als Hörbuch an
Bei Audible
Wobei, jetzt wenn ich drüber nachdenke
Man kann sich das doch bestimmt auch als Linux-Distribution runterladen, oder?
Aber das wollen wir nicht.
Audible.
Ich habe es mir bei Audible gekauft.
Das ist das beste ISO, ja? Ist das so?
Okay, also, was können wir uns denn angucken hier?
Was haben wir denn da?
Smart Meter Chaos.
Warum Verbraucher draufzahlen?
acht minuten das kann auch ein klarer praxis auch
nie das wollte ich mir angucken microsoft band wireguard vera crypt
winscribe was zum teufel ist winscribe vpn
das ist bestimmt auch lustig every major windows fuck up explained in acht
minuten damit fangen damit fangen wir an das
klingt gut every major windows fuck up explained
Acht Minuten reichen da nicht.
Der muss verdammt schnell sein in acht Minuten, oder?
Okay.
Ja.
Das stimmt.
Und das Witzige ist, das Startmenü hat einfach funktioniert.
Die Suche hat noch nie gut funktioniert, ja?
Aber das Startmenü hat einfach funktioniert.
Nicht so wie dieses Kackding hier.
Oh ja!
Aber die haben das danach doch gefixt, oder?
Windows 8.1 oder was es dann da gab.
Ja, das war so, ich habe bis heute nicht verstanden, warum.
Ich glaube, das war, weil die damals quasi auf Tablet und Smartphones mit Windows Konkurrenz machen wollten
und gedacht haben, wir brauchen so einen unified Look für Windows Smartphones, Tablets und Windows.
Nur, dass die Leute es halt überhaupt nicht wollten.
Richtig dumm.
Wie nannte sich dieses Kacheldesign nochmal?
Metro? War das Metro?
Metro Design?
Ist das nicht so?
Metro Design, ja.
Das mit diesen Kacheln, genau.
Wobei, ehrlich gesagt, ich bin mir gar nicht mal sicher.
Ey, das neue Startmenü, das ist aber auch so dermaßen beschissen, Alter.
Das ist so dumm.
Ich benutze das Startmenü an sich ja gar nicht mehr.
Ich tippe hier höchstens nochmal irgendwas ein, aber...
Boah, das ist so... Glücklicherweise mache ich das meist ja unter Linux.
Warum überhaupt Windows?
Naja, für Streaming, für Gaming, für Videos schneiden, für Thumbnails erstellen.
Ihr müsst mir jetzt nicht erzählen, dass ich schon lange nichts mehr gemacht habe.
Ja, aber dafür.
Windows XP war Peak, meiner Meinung nach.
where many users avoided upgrading, or would install third-party tools to restore the old
Start Menu.
Microsoft partially reversed this in Windows 8.1 and eventually brought back a redesigned
Start Menu in Windows 10, acknowledging the failure of the Start Screen.
Around 2015, following the release of Windows 10, Microsoft began rolling out an aggressive
upgrade campaign.
This came in the form of a background application known as GW-
Sag mal, war das gerade mein Kopf, der gesponnen hat, oder hat sich dieses Fenster gerade irgendwie
bewegt?
Microsoft began rolling out-
Ja, oder?
Chat, bin ich dumm oder kippt sich dieses Windows hier?
Das bewegt sich doch, oder?
Ja, es kippt. Okay, okay, ich bin nicht der Einzige, der das sieht.
Ich hab schon gedacht, ich drehe durch.
... Upgrade Campaign.
This came in the form of a background application known as GWX,
short for Get Windows 10,
which quietly installed itself through standard system updates.
It placed a small white Windows logo in the system tray
and offered users a free upgrade.
Ich sehe eh noch nicht.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade wieder beim Thema sind, ich habe es ja schon oft gesagt,
wir waren noch nie so nah am Jahr des Linux-Desktops wie 2026,
aber auch 2026 wird nicht das Jahr des Linux-Desktops sein.
Ich denke nicht, dass es jemals so das große Jahr geben wird. Das wird ein schleichender Prozess sein. Aber der größte Pluspunkt für Linux oder der größte Grund, warum Linux in den letzten zwei Jahren so viele User gewonnen hat, ist meiner Meinung nach gar nicht mal primär, dass Linux um so viele Faktoren besser geworden ist.
Also gerade Wayland hat sich die letzten drei, vier Jahre deutlich verbessert.
Das war ja ein kompletter Abfuck.
Jetzt ist es nur noch ein bisschen Abfuck.
Der größte Faktor die letzten Jahre über,
neben Steam natürlich, ja, keine Frage,
aber worauf ich raus will, ist der größte Faktor meiner Meinung nach,
ist Microsoft selbst.
Mein Microsoft macht ja alles, um Windows noch beschissener zu machen.
Es vergeht ja keine Woche oder kein Monat mehr,
wo irgendwas noch beschissener gemacht wird in Windows.
Oh Mann.
Ja, hat Microsoft zu viel Vibe codet, hä?
Das kommt mir noch bekannt vor, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Also, ich hatte den Fehler nicht.
Aber ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Es würde einen Blutbildschirm von der Todesgeschichte trinken, der oft das Errorcode APC Index Mismatch
ansieht, das zu einem Komponenten von Windows-Kompetenzen verbunden war.
Der Crash war konsistent und reproduzierbar, aber nur nach bestimmten Bedingungen,
meistens, wenn man bestimmte Applikationen mit älteren Type-3-Printer-Drivers benutzt.
Im Grunde könnte der Computer perfekt funktionieren während normaler...
Ist das Max? Nein, nein, nein, ich bin Wubblos!
Aber schön, dass du deinen Weg hierher gefunden hast.
Server Setup in der Kammer.
Ja, das habe ich immer noch.
Only to completely crash the moment a print command was issued.
Because this was a mandatory security update,
many systems installed it automatically,
especially in schools, offices and even...
Gab es nicht letztens das Problem,
dass Leute nicht mehr auf ihr C-Laufwerk zugreifen konnten
mit einem Windows-Update?
...hospitals, which as you could imagine was pretty bad.
Initial workarounds required uninstalling the update
or disabling printing...
Nein, nein, nein, ich habe vier NAS.
Nicht fünf, das fünfte habe ich mir nicht gekauft.
Ich habe meinen HP-Micro-Server, das ist das, was ich...
Das ist ein Ukraine, noch ein Ukraine und das Minisforum.
full context menu from the early days.
Ey, das ist auch komplett dämlich, ey.
Das ist so nervig.
Also der meint ja das hier, guck.
Show more options.
Das ist so hängen geblieben, Alter.
Also ernsthaft, wer bei Microsoft auf die Idee gekommen ist,
das wäre eine gute Idee.
Das muss auch Chat-GPT ausgespuckt haben
oder Copilot musste auf die Idee gekommen sein.
Das ist so unglaublich hängen geblieben.
Ich bin übrigens immer noch zu dumm, ne?
Wenn ich hier jetzt das renamen will...
Ach, mittlerweile haben sie es sogar drunter geschrieben.
Chat, Chat, ist das neu, dass es drunter steht?
Früher waren das nur Icons, gell?
Und keiner hat gecheckt, welches Icon was sein sollte.
Ja, ja, das ist neu, weil es keiner kapiert hat.
...
muss, weil's Microsoft verkackt.
Das war ja mal eine Zeit lang Candy Crush und so vorinstalliert
unter Windows zehn. Das ist jetzt glaube ich noch mal so.
Das habe ich ja schon gesagt.
gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Ja, auch richtig dumm, ey.
Ja, die Settings-App kann man eh vergessen.
Oh ja.
Es ist doch mittlerweile sogar so, dass du Windows 11 Home nicht mehr ohne Microsoft Account überhaupt installieren kannst
und dass sie so gut wie alle Sachen ausgebaut haben, die das früher erlaubt haben.
Professional geht der immer noch.
Wenn es ja auch immer geil, dass man beim Installieren von Windows erstmal 30 Mal klicken muss.
Nein, nein, nein.
Und bei manchen Sachen kannst du nicht mal Nein drücken, da kannst du sagen, nur minimal Nein, Nein, Nein.
Oh yeah.
Microsoft 365 Copilot Chat GPT LLM App.
Was ist eigentlich aus Windows Recall geworden?
Da haben die einen Rückzieher gemacht, ne?
Das war diese Geschichte, die dein Desktop alle paar Sekunden fotografiert und speichert.
Ungefragt.
Windows. It means almost every
Copilot opening was accidental.
Alongside this, keyboard shortcuts like
Win plus C were reassigned to launch Copilot.
When opened, Copilot appears as a
sidebar that slides into view, occupying
a portion of the screen and moving any open
window. It's not bad design by
itself, but it's super distracting.
Was, Windows C?
Äh, was?
Customize Copilot Key, non-selected.
Okay. Habe ich diesen Shit immer noch installiert?
Ne, habe ich aninstalliert.
Was soll da Microsoft 365 Copilot Mist überhaupt können?
Die Office App wurde doch umbenannt. Das ist die Office App nur umbenannt.
mich wunderts, dass er Windows Recall da nicht drin hat
aber ich mein's aber so, Microsoft hat sicherlich noch mehr
Fuckups, ich sag nur Windows Vista oder sowas
wobei Windows Vista viele gute Sachen so als Grundlage gelegt hat
so das Windows Composite, Windows Zeug, was heute noch aktiv ist
Also hat sich ja vieles getan, aber das war nicht sonderlich well received.
Okay, so, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Smart Meta-Cows.
Nee, Microsoft Band, Microsoft Band, Wireguard und das muss ich mir mal angucken.
Wobei meines Wissens nach, das können wir gleich nochmal nachgucken, ob das stimmt,
Aber ich bilde mir ein, ich habe das gesehen.
Der Account ist wieder unlocked.
Vom Vera Crypt Entwickler.
Wenn du eins machen müsstest,
nur noch Windows als Main verwenden,
keine vor allem erlaubt oder nur C++?
Oh, scheiße.
Fuck, Alter, das ist eine gute Frage.
Boah, das ist beides mega beschissen.
Okay, das würde ja dann auch bedeuten...
Nee, nee, nee, okay.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, dann wäre es nur...
Oh, das ist aber auch richtig krasser.
Abfangen und auch C++ verwenden.
Aber ich glaube, das wäre dann nur noch C++ verwenden,
weil ich meine, ich programmiere jetzt nicht 24-7 den ganzen Tag.
Da wäre mir Linux immer noch lieber,
weil das würde ja auch bedeuten,
Ich habe kein Linux auf Servern, ich habe nichts mehr.
Ja, nee, nee, okay.
Dann würde ich nur noch C++ programmieren, aber weiterhin Linux verwenden.
Microsoft hat gerade drei der wichtigsten Open-Source-Sicherheitsprojekte aus ihren Entwicklungsakkaunten gelockt,
mit null Warnung, null Erklärung und null Anruf.
Und ich muss darüber sprechen.
Diese drei Projekte...
Kann ich mir nicht angucken, das Video.
...einen Account.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken. Man merkt ja schon, dass das nervig ist.
Das ist bestimmt auch.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich habe, warte mal, Veracrypt, genau, weil man das so ordentlich schreibt.
Veracryptforum. Ich bilde mir ein, ich habe das gesehen im Veracryptforum.
Die sind aus irgendwelchen Gründen immer noch auf Sourceforge.
Whatever.
General Discussion.
Project Update
hier habe ich das glaube ich gesehen und da hat er
auf der, das hier ist der
das ist der Hauptentwickler
von Veracrypt
hier, hier guck
I have regained access to my Microsoft Partner
center account das gott hanselmann hat ihm geholfen also wird sich das in weiß präsident sich darum kümmern muss
Aber das ist hat sich anscheinend wieder erledigt keine ahnung was microsoft da wieder
geritten hat
entweder
wollten sie den kram aktiv ausschalten dass die leute bitlocker verwenden oder
Irgendeine KI hat das gemacht.
Und ganz ehrlich, bei Microsoft kann ich mir auch vorstellen,
dass das irgendeine KI gemacht hat.
So nach dem Motto,
KI, scanne mir mal alle Microsoft-Partner-Accounts,
ob da irgendwas verdächtig ist, und dann banne die.
Zack.
Dieses Bild, kann ich mich trauen, das anzuklicken?
What happens when you name everything Copilot?
Ja.
Moment, das sind ernsthaft Sachen, die es alles gibt, oder was?
Microsoft has applied the name Cope to 80?
Alter, was zum Teufel? Wirklich?
GitHub Copilot in GitHub Mobile.
Haha, was ein Scheißnamen, Alter.
Das gibt doch nicht wirklich was, was GitHub Copilot in GitHub Mobile heißt, oder?
GitHub Copilot Pro Plus.
Copilot in Paint.
Microsoft Security Copilot
Azure Copilot
ach du
Scheiße, Copilot in
Microsoft Entra
was sind die Pfeile?
Line links
Copilot that overlap
bundle together or sit in
inside one another.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ja, und Microsoft
versteht gar nicht, warum die Leute was
gegen AI haben, gell? Kann man ja auch gar nicht nachvollziehen.
Und man soll sich ja auch mal bitteschön nicht so abfällig gegenüber KI-Sachen äußern.
Sagt der Microsoft-Chef.
Die Gefahr von Abos und warum sie überall sind.
Und, naja, die Gefahr von Abos ist eher, dass man Abo abschließend dann vergisst und für was bezahlt, was man eigentlich gar nicht benutzt.
Würde ich mal sagen.
Die typische Praktikumserfahrung ist, Gema-Kisten aufräumen.
Das Schufa-Video ist gut.
Oh, nee.
Tim Apple.
Der tragische Absturz von Need for Speed.
Ja, von Need for Speed hört man ja die letzten Jahre über nichts mehr.
Und das relativ sicher auch ganz zu Recht.
Seven Levels of Desk Setups.
Okay, das klingt...
Also mein Desk Setup ist nicht schön anzusehen.
Liegen ziemlich viele Kabel rum und hängen hinterm Tisch.
runter ich habe zwei monitore tastatur maus geschert dazwischen drei pcs stream
vorschau rechner gaming rechner mini pc für linux controller rumliegen
also ich habe ich habe eher das
Ich glaub mal gehen. Ich hab eher das unordentliche Desk-Setup.
Was ist das? Telekom Aktionärsversammlung.
Der Chef rät Kritikern, gehen sie doch woanders hin.
Aha. Zeig mal her.
Aktionärsversammlung vom 1.
Wenn sie nicht zufrieden sind mit unseren
Diensten und Millionen Kunden, verlassen sie
Verlassen sie nicht drauf, dann
Achso
Ja gut
Kann man mal machen, ja
Ich erinnere nochmal dran
Das hat
Dice
Bei Battlefield 1
Es erinnert sich vielleicht noch einer dran, auch gemacht
Da haben die ja so Dinger gesagt wie, wenn euch das nicht gefällt, dann spielt was anderes oder was haben sie noch gesagt, wir stehen auf der richtigen Seite der Geschichte, wer das anders sieht, soll sich...
Das Problem ist nur, dass man in vielen Fällen halt, wenn nur Telekom verfügbar ist, nicht an der Telekom vorbeikommt.
Thomas Lohninger
von der Nichtregierungsorganisation
Epicenterworks
der
200 Aktien der Kritik
kritisierte bei der Veranstaltung
das Peering der Telekom, ja
das ist ein guter Kritikpunkt
üblicherweise sind Peering
vereinbar unentgeltlich, ja gut
die Telekom und Cloudflare, Daten fließen umgehend
inzwischen.
Dies sei bei der Telekom anders.
Wenn nicht bezahlt, ist im Netz der Telekom
nur schlecht verfügbar.
Tja, ist halt halt ein Kackladen, ne?
Ähm.
Bei der Telekom
funktioniere das Internet nur, wenn an beiden
Händen Geld gezahlt wird. Egal, ob
Direkt für die Zusammenschaltung oder indirekt an einen Hoster, Content Delivery Network, VPN oder Transitbetreiber, der die Telekom bezahlt.
Nur wenn Geld fließt, dann fließt die Daten umgehend. Dies sei das parate Beispiel für eine Verletzung der Netzneutralität.
Ja, da würde ich ihm zustimmen.
Der Höttges widersprach, ich bestreite diese Aussagen, die er getroffen hat.
Das kann man immer geil sagen, ne?
So nach dem Motto, blau ist blau und grün ist grün.
Ich bestreite diese Aussagen, die er getroffen hat.
Ja, schön. Und was sagst du dagegen?
Die Telekom weise den Vorwurf, ihr Netz künstlich zu verknappen oder Datenschritten irgendwo zu verlangsamen, ausdrücklich zurück.
Die Telekom gewinne sämtliche
Netztests
Was sollen das für Tests sein?
Das ist doch einfach nur
Heiße Luft, leeres Gelaber
Was für einen Test
Soll das bitte schön sein?
Ein Download-Test von meinem Telekom-Anschluss gegen einen Telekom-Server, oder was?
Die Telekom schaffe künstliche Engpässe?
Und wo hat er jetzt gesagt?
Wo anders hin?
Weiß man jetzt gar nicht.
Hat er es in diesem Zuge gesagt, oder?
Es gab lange Zeit und gibt es glaube ich immer noch ich habe kein Telekom Anschluss ich weiß
es nicht Probleme mit allem was Cloudflare betrifft.
Okay, das würde ich schon mal nett aushalten, weil es muss ein Stuhl, also das ist aus meiner
Sicht ganz zwingend, weil
Chat könnte mir ja mal sagen, wie ihr das seht, ein Stuhl
mit Armlehnen.
Und am besten
breiten Armlehnen. Ich habe ja seit
Jahren schon diesen hier.
Ich habe ja seit Jahren schon diesen Stuhl
hier.
Den da.
Weiß nicht, ob man da gescheiten Bilder von sieht.
Den hier. Und der ist
pock.
der ist wirklich
pock, du kannst
die Armlehnen dreidimensional
verstellen, die kannst du quasi links
rechts, vorne, hinten
hoch, runter machen
ähm
also dementsprechend auch diagonal
und sowas
und es gibt für alles Ersatzteile
und der Stuhl, ich hab den über 10 Jahre schon
der ist wie neu
der macht überhaupt keine Anstalten
und der ist auch mega stabil
Ich glaube, der ist zugelassen bis 250 Kilo. Ich wiege aktuell ein bisschen über 80 Kilo. Ich hatte bei meinem alten Stuhl das Problem, wenn man davon schnell aufgestanden ist, sich abgestürzt hat und sich hochgedrückt hat, da wirkt vielleicht auch mal kurzzeitig ein bisschen mehr als 80 Kilo drauf.
und da ist mir mal bei
einem DX Racer Stuhl
ist mir die Armlehne
aus dem Rahmen rausgebrochen
aber hier, ohne Scheiß, das ist
so massiv Metall und alles
das Ding ist mega stabil und
top
so, Link
mach mal Ausrufezeichen Stuhl
ich glaube ich hab sogar einen Link
im Chat
ja, so sieht der aus
das einzige Problem bei dem Stuhl ist
Achso, ich hab's mit...
Ich hab's mit dieser Kopflehne,
aber ich hab da noch ein Kissen dran.
Das einzige Problem bei diesem Stuhl ist,
weil das sehen wir jetzt hier auch mal bei Amazon,
dass
der Stuhl
relativ teuer
sein kann.
Stuhl auch für große Menschen.
Würde schon sagen, passt, ja.
Konnte man mal nicht hier Produkte suchen?
Ja, das ist halt das Problem, dass man über 1500 Euro für den Stuhl bezahlt.
Ich kann euch aber ehrlich sagen, wenn ihr in irgendeiner Art und Weise Geld verdient mit vorm Rechner sitzen, ist das eine Überlegung wert.
Weil warum sparen bei was
Was man irgendwie gefühlt 24-7 benutzt
Das sind 3 Nass
Das sind nicht 3 Nass mit RAM
Das sind wenn es hoch kommt 3 Nass
Wenn es hoch kommt
Sind es 2
Es sind 1,5 Nass
Das ist ein leeres Nass und ein gut bestücktes Nass
Und mit Festplatten
Ist das genau 1 Nass
also ein voll bestücktes nass und weniger weniger als ein voll bestücktes
nass wenn du nass mit ram ssds und platten haben willst bezahlst du mehr
also den stuhl kann ich ohne mist wirklich komplett empfehlen das ist der
beste stuhl den ich kenne und gute stühle sind ihr geld wert
Warum ich mir das gekauft habe, liegt daran, ich kannte den Stuhl schon.
Wir hatten den gleichen Stuhl bei uns, dort wo das Support gesessen hat, die mit Schichtarbeit und 24-7-Verfügbarkeit.
Ich habe ja quasi dort in so einem separaten Abteil gehockt.
Ich habe nicht beim Support da gearbeitet, aber die hatten so eine Monitorwand und diese
Sitze und da halt auch diese Stühle.
Und ich habe da in der Nähe gesessen, in so einem separaten Abteil und da konnte ich
den Stuhl hier regelmäßig ausprobieren und der war super.
Und dann habe ich mich irgendwann dafür entschieden, so ein geiler Stuhl, den kaufst
du dir auch für daheim.
Hast du eine teure Matratze?
Geht so.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, weil ich habe irgendwas von Ikea, glaube ich.
Stuhl ist wichtig.
Du hast den hier.
Schreibt dich Stuhl Kolonialzeit.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Das ist alles andere
als ein guter Arbeits-PC-Stuhl.
Da tun dir ja die Ärmel weh,
wenn du die Armlehnen verwendest.
Du benutzt den wirklich?
Ernsthaft?
Also ich weiß nicht.
Ohne Polster und ohne breite Auflage für die Ellenbogen und Ärmel.
Nee, das könnte ich nicht.
Ja, 1500 Euro musst du schon mit rechnen.
So, dann gucken wir mal weiter.
Was haben wir denn für...
Genau, Desk-Setups wollte ich gucken.
Aber so runde Tische sind auch
sad.
Und wisst ihr, es gibt genug Leute,
die das machen, die in der Küche arbeiten.
Alles okay,
jeder, was ihm gefällt und Bock macht.
Was mich immer richtig abfuckt,
wenn die Leute in der Küche arbeiten, Homeoffice machen
und dann irgendwie die Kinder drumherum
rennen um den Tisch und sowas.
dass generell so Lärm von Leuten in Meetings
geht mir immer so auf den Keks.
Ja, ich sage nichts dagegen,
wenn ab und zu mal die Kinder reinflitzen,
dann werden die wieder rausgeschickt
und dann ist gut, da kannst du nichts dagegen machen.
Aber Leute, die permanent Krache im Hintergrund haben,
dann irgendwie auch zu blöd sind,
ihr Mikrofon zu muten,
das geht mir immer richtig auf den Sack.
Die haben wohl keine Wahl.
Ja, das mag sein, aber es muss mir trotzdem nicht gefallen.
Manche Leute, die auch nicht ihre Mikrofonsettings
richtig checken und aus versehen dann das dass das das onboard mikro verwenden was ich so an
als hätten sie es verschluckt ja ich habe mein kollege da war froh dass er auf die arbeit kommen
Ich habe einen Standing Desk. Ich benutze die Standing Funktion sehr selten.
Ja.
Aber etwas ist falsch. Das ist nicht das, was du erwartet hast.
Das ist nicht das, was du online gesehen hast.
Die liegt jetzt dort in meinem Spind und jedes Mal, wenn ich da anrücke, wird die ausgepackt und angeschlossen.
Ich habe eine, falls das jemand interessiert, ich habe auf der Arbeit eine Ducky One Skyline, aber die Full Size Tastatur, das Ding hier, ne, mit NumBlock, noch mit NumBlock.
Noch mit NumBlock, NumBlock, nicht NumBlock, Num, NumBlock.
also eine Full Size, die hier
ne, aber die mit der normalen europäischen
Enter-Taste
wo man irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen keine Bilder
dazu findet, aber okay
ja, mit NumBlock
hab ich die
ja, mit NumBlock, dieses Ding
top
ähm
und dann hab ich ne
Logitech MX
ne ne ne
ich glaub ne G502
Otus Core
so ne alte Gaming Maus
das ist mein Arbeitssetup
darfst du ohne Probleme auf der Arbeit
fremde USB Geräte anschließen
zum Glück ist das erlaubt
bei Maus und Tastatur
ich würde durchdrehen wenn ich die
die die dort vor Ort vorhandene Maus und Tastatur verwenden muss.
Ja, das ist so Kombination,
wie es bei mir aussieht.
Jetzt kommitierst du darauf, dieses Ding einmal und für alle zu bauen.
Aber du hast einige feste Boundare.
Die Setups, die du online siehst, sprechen alle über Schuhe.
Ja, das sind aber auch so Hipster-Setups.
Mit Rubik's Cube, irgendwelchen komischen 3D-Getrunkten.
Das sind so Hipster-Setups.
Mit RGB-Beleuchtung und sowas.
Scheiß drauf. Brauchen wir nicht.
Schuhe, Monitore, Accessories, die kosten...
Und der Tisch ist viel zu klein.
Da ist überhaupt kein Platz.
...tausende Dollar.
Du weißt, dass du ein Setup kreieren kannst,
das du für eine Fragung des Preises freust.
Everything arrives and you assemble it with care.
And finally you sit down and think about how far you've come already.
Just a week ago you were stuck working in a space that wasn't even yours.
Sitting in a chair that wasn't comfortable.
A table that didn't stay stable.
Daheim, wo wir gerade dabei sind, die Maus, die ich daheim habe, ist eine Logitech Wireless Pro, heißt das Ding, glaube ich.
Ähm, Maus.
das Ding.
Und das habe ich,
weil, und das finde ich,
ist eine richtig gute Kombi,
weil, ja, ja, ich war auch
kein Wireless-Maus-Fan,
weil es gibt ein Maus-Pad
dafür.
Ähm.
Charging-Maus-Pad.
Es gibt ein Maus-Pad dafür,
dass die Maus auflädt.
Also im Prinzip ist meine Maus nur 4-5 cm Wireless.
Also die Maus ist hier und das USB-Kabel ist da.
Also ich merke da auch keinen Lag oder irgendwas.
Und das Ding lädt die Maus auf.
Das heißt, man hat keine Maus.
Man muss da nicht irgendwie mit einem Maus-Bungie
oder irgendeinem Kack rumhantieren.
Maus, komplett wireless, wunderbar
Aber automatisches Chargen
Für mich beste Kombi
Habe ich auch seit Jahren schon
Würde ich mir auch jederzeit wieder kaufen
Wieso ist der Akku ein Problem?
Naja, wenn dich das nicht nervt mit dem Aufmachen
Das ist kein Ding, also ich finde es so halt richtig top
Und ich meine, ein Mauspad brauchst du eh
Ja, insofern, warum nicht ein Mousepad, was er auflädt?
Also ganz ehrlich, so ordentlich sieht man technisch aus.
Fängt ja schon an, dass hier vor mir random ein ESP32 halb auf einem Breadboard draufgesteckt liegt,
wo ich gar nicht mehr weiß, was der da eigentlich macht und warum.
Wozu er das Buch da hat? Das Buch hat er, weil es gut aussieht, nicht weil es sinnvoll ist.
Außerdem viel zu wenig Platz für die Maus.
Wie soll man da Low Sense spielen?
Ja, also die Maus, das ist viel zu wenig Platz.
Also ich kann auch nicht komplett
Low Sense spielen, ne?
Erstens, weil mir das irgendwie so instinktiv nicht liegt
Und weil das Mauspad
Zu klein ist. Die richtig krassen
Low Sense Leute, die irgendwie
CSGO spielen und die müssen ja
Ohne Scheiß, da gibt's ja
Da gibt's ja Mauspads
Die gehen ja über den
Die gehen ja ohne Scheiß über den ganzen Tisch.
Das reicht noch nicht.
Es gibt Mauspads, die gehen halb über den Tisch.
Die sind sogar so groß,
dass da steht die Tastatur mit drauf.
Ja.
Das ist für die ganzen Low-Sense-Enjoyer.
Sowas.
Die brauchen ja mindestens einen Meter dafür, dass die sich halb rumdrehen können.
... und nicht nur, dass man die Tastatur zu klein lesen kann. Und ist nicht dein Keyboard einfach ein bisschen zu muschig und unkonsistent?
den mit meiner mechanischen Tastatur auf den Sack. Kommt mir so vor. Obwohl ich da schon
Silikonringe drunter habe unter den Tasten, wo ich immer besonders drauf haue.
Ah, Katze.
Ja, das brauch ich nicht.
Und wichtig, wichtig Leute, RGB.
Ein Deskschelf, da habe ich ja noch nie dran gedacht.
Ihr Lieblings hat immer noch viel zu wenig Platz für die Maus.
Also diese Trinkdinger
Brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe so eine Trinkflasche.
Die finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Die ist aus einem Plastik, was nicht nach Plastik schmeckt, wenn man da Wasser reinfüllt.
Jetzt kriegen wir erstmal Cell Audit.
Schauen wir kurz ein bisschen weiter.
220 pounds.
Pippo Fett.
Der Stuhl hat glaube ich 250
Kilo, den ich euch vorhin gezeigt habe.
Moment, ist das immer noch Sellout?
Ist das immer noch Sellout?
Moment, Moment, das Video ist ja komplett,
das ist ja zur Hälfte Sellout. What the fuck?
Where were we?
Level 6. Financial
Irresponsibility. You've
Was ist denn das für ein abgedrehter Stuhl?
Und vor allem, warum hat er da eine Kopfstütze und wo gar kein Kopf ist?
Also das wichtigste an dem ganzen Schreibtisch ist die Ablagefläche für die Cuts.
Sie schauen sich jetzt die Test-Setups an, die Sie online genutzt haben und realisieren, dass sie nicht sogar ihre loftigen Standards treffen.
Und einige Leute escape nie von dieser Stelle.
Einige Leute erreichen nie Level 7.
Und die Hälfte von meinem Unterarm liegen auf dem Mauspad.
Vielleicht nur für einen Wechsel des Rückschlags.
Aber wenn du dich zu deinem Desk-Setup befindest,
regierst du nicht die Geld, die du verwendest,
oder wünschst, dass du mehr verwendest.
Du verstanden alle kleinen Details,
alle funktionellen Nuancen,
weil es dich an deinen Reise-Tour erinnert.
Dein Desk-Setup ist nicht mehr etwas, das du besitzt,
sondern wiederum etwas, das du besitzt.
Weil das lustige an Desk-Setups ist,
dass das Ziel niemals der Desk war.
Es war die Bildung...
ein Problem. Ich bin jetzt schon
drei Stunden on. Wenn ich noch
viel länger on bleibe, dann kann
ich heute Mittag nicht mehr Niri streamen.
Aber wir wollen doch heute Mittag Niri
streamen, oder?
Schau dir mal
Voting.
What?
Okay.
Das kann ich mir nochmal
anschauen.
Niri ist ein Window Manager.
Nudel mit Lachs.
Es gibt heute tatsächlich Lachs,
aber es gibt Reis mit Lachs.
Okay, und was
zeichnet die Dinger so aus?
Das ist der gleiche Dude von eben, ne?
Oder?
Aber das ist...
Ich brauche ohne Scheiß
einen ordentlichen Num-Block
da dran. Ich kriege Anfälle.
Und mit der anderen Anordnung
von diesen Tasten kriege ich auch Anfälle.
Products.
60%
Ich brauch das voll, ich brauch
Full Size.
Baby, Baby, es gibt Reis.
Oh Gott, ich dachte, den Kram kennt
keiner.
Das ist, ähm,
hört euch das nicht an, das geht euch nicht mehr
aus dem Kopf. Das ist von,
das ist von Helge Schneider.
Schüttel
dein Haar für mich, es gibt Reis.
so unglaublich dumm, Alter.
Es gibt Reis, lecker, lecker.
Aber die haben kein
Full-Size-Keyboard.
Das ist für mich schon unusable.
Ich brauche Full-Size-Keyboard.
Geht das noch jemand so,
Chat? Kommt ihr
damit klar, mit
so
80 und 60 Prozent,
Tastaturen? Doch, haben die?
Nee, haben die nicht.
Haben die nicht.
Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht mehr sicher, wie...
Das ist Full-Size?
Das ist Full-Size. Aber RGB-ed as fuck ist das.
Separates Numpad.
Nee, nee, nee.
So muss eine Tastatur aussehen.
Wobei man sagen muss, das ist AMI-Layout.
Ich bevorzuge die deutsche Enter-Taste.
Wofür benutzt du Numpad?
Naja, um Nummern einzugeben.
zum Beispiel.
Manchmal zumindest.
Ich benutze das NumPad lieber als das hier
für Nummern.
Die haben auch ISO.de
Wo kann man das einstellen?
Order now.
Aha.
ISO.
So.
Excellent.
What?
Wotting.
Und warum, was ist an dem jetzt besonders geil, Chat?
Also warum sollte man sich das kaufen?
Hall-Effekt-Switches? Was?
Was sollen denn Hall-Effekt-Switches sein?
magnetische switches das ist noch mal was anderes ist das sind keine rubber domes
keine mechanischen switches sind magnetische switches
Moment, analoge Switches?
Das sind analoge Switches?
Also sprich, das kenne ich, aber...
Ah ja, ja gut, das ist natürlich nice.
Da kann man in Spielen so laufen, wie mit einem Controller zum Beispiel.
Weiß nicht.
Ich war's nicht, Leute.
Äh.
Ich bleib bei meiner Tastatur.
Ich hab hier ne Logitech,
keine Ahnung, steht nix drauf.
Mit so ner Handballenauflage
davor, damit bin ich eigentlich ganz happy.
Die macht's jetzt auch
schon ein paar Jahre. Nicht so wie diese
komische Corsa-Tastatur,
die doppelte Anschläge
hatte nach einem halben Jahr.
Was hältst du von Neusen mit einem Analogstick dran?
Hatte ich noch nie.
Finde ich eine spannende Sache.
Ja.
Aber
ich kann mir jetzt gerade kein Workflow dafür
vorstellen.
Ich könnte mir
vorstellen für Video-Editing und sowas,
das ist mega nice.
Okay, Chat.
Chat. Ich weiß, es ist erst
11.40 Uhr, aber
ich gehe jetzt off, was essen
und dann gucken wir mal, dass wir
heute Mittag uns Niri angucken. Aber da kann ich euch
gleich sagen, es wird wahrscheinlich mindestens mal
zwei, also ich sage mal, ich tippe mal auf drei Streams
geben, wo wir uns Niri angucken,
plus die ganzen Shells drumherum.
Wir müssen das natürlich vom Scratch einrichten.
Und ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher,
ob ich es auf dem Linux Mini
PC mache oder zum Einrichten erstmal
in einer VM. Ich glaube, erstmal
auf einer VM zum Einrichten.
So, Chat, wir sehen uns höchstwahrscheinlich, ich kann es nicht versprechen, ihr kennt mich, aber höchstwahrscheinlich bis später. Macht's gut, CU.